podcaster conversation d'avenir et un
monde de bulle réagir et participer aux
18h et à bouge lafance c'est sur public
scena.fr le site de la chaîne
d'information
politique bonjour à tous ravi de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat dans un
instant vous allez pouvoir suivre
l'examen d'une proposition de loi très
controversée il s'agit de la proposition
de loi sur le travail du dimanche cette
proposition de loi prévoit que le
travail dominical est de droit sans
doublement de salaire ni repos
compensateur dans les communes d'intérêt
touristique elle serait au nombre de 500
selon le gouvernement 10 fois plus selon
l'opposition qui dénonce un texte qui
vise à généraliser le travail le
dimanche les sénateurs de gauche ont
annoncé qu'ils voteront contre ce texte
ils ont publié lundi une tribune dans le
journal Libération ils estiment que le
dimanche c'est ce que les Français ont
en commun 137 amendements et 3ois
motions de procédure ont été déposées
sur ce texte alors que la majorité
sénatoriale a voté conforme en
commission si ce texte est voté en
séance son adoption sera définitive
voilà pour les enjeux de la séance que
je vous propose de suivre tout de suite
bon après-midi à tous sur Public
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
réaffirmant le principe du repos
dominical et visant à adapter les
dérogations à ce principe dans les
communes et zones touristiques et
thermal ainsi que dans certaines grandes
agglomérations pour les salariés
volontaires dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Xavier D'cos
ministre du Travail des Relations
sociales de la Famille de la Solidarité
de la ville je voudrais auparavant
saluer madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
et non pas pour la première fois mais
dans ces fonctions là et lui souhaiter
mes meilleurs vux de réussite dans les
fonctions qui lui ont été confié
monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le
président madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales je me
joins au vœux et aux félicitations du
président de la Haute Assemblée madame
le rapporteur chère Isabelle debr
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs puon de loi qui vous est
soumise aujourd'hui est le fruit d'un
long et patient travail
d'élaboration ce travail a mobilisé
pendant plusieurs mois parlementaires
élus locaux acteurs du monde économique
partenaires sociaux autour d'une seule
et même
préoccupation faire progresser notre
droit sans faire régresser nos valeurs
ce point d'équilibre auquel nous sommes
parvenus au terme d'un débat long mais
constructif à l'Assemblée nationale sur
le texte présenté par le député Richard
maillet permettez-moi de saluer ce point
d'équilibre et de saluer aussi le
travail exemplaire de votre rapporteur
Isabelle Debray qui a travaillé depuis
le début de l'élaboration de ce texte en
parfaite collaboration avec Richard
maillet et permettez-moi enfin de
remercier la commission des affaires
sociales pour son dynamisme et pour son
efficacité sous la présidence
de
mugini ce débat doit à présent se
poursuivre avec vous pour permettre
l'élaboration puis l'adoption du texte
définitif la discussion qui s'engage
aujourd'hui est d'autant plus importante
que l'équilibre auquel nous sommes
parvenus dans ce texte donne vous le
savez un rôle très important à
l'initiative locale à celle des élus il
va de soit en effet que les élus locaux
que vous représentez sont les mieux à
même d'identifier les besoins des
entreprises des salariés des ménages qui
vivent dans les 36000 communes de notre
pays il était donc légitime que le
revint l'initiative de mettre en œuvre
le nouvel équilibre que propose ce texte
un équilibre qui respecte les valeurs de
notre société mais qui prend acte aussi
de ses évolutions et il apporte des
réponses
nécessaires ce texte
venons-y réaffirme d'abord un principe
fondamental du vivre ensemble auquel
nous sommes tous attachés celui du repos
dominical pour voir se reposer le
dimanche prendre le temps de se
retrouver en famille profiter d'un
espace dédié au loisirs c'est un élément
essentiel à la qualité de la vie dans
notre pays c'est une demande légitime
des salariés c'est une conquête sociale
que nul ne songe ici à remettre en cause
et surtout pas ce texte dans sa
rédaction actuelle qui réaffirme je cite
dans l'intérêt des sal AR le repos
hebdomadaire et donné le
dimanche ce texte adopte les dérogations
administrative au repos dominical qui
permett de donner le repos hebdomadaire
par roulement au personnel il les adapte
comme cela d'ailleurs a été fait depuis
plusieurs reprises à plusieurs reprises
depuis
1906 ce texte prend acte du fait que le
principe du repau dominical a toujours
été appliqué avec pragmatisme pour
répondre aux attentes au besoins
de notre société pour répondre aux
spécificité de l'activité économique de
telle ou telle partie du territoire
c'est sans doute d'ailleurs la souplesse
avec laquelle a été appliqué la règle du
repos dominical qui a permis d'en
préserver le principe le texte qui vous
est soumis n'a nullement pour viser de
dicter le droit d'après le fait il
permet au contraire de mieux encadrer
les conditions d'ouverture dominicale
dans les endroits de notre territoire où
ell s'avè non seulement utile mais même
évidente ce texte encadre m les
dérogations administratives prévues dans
le code du travail emportant plus de
cohérence au système et en conférant de
nouveaux droits aux salariés sur les 6
millions et demi de salariés qui
travaillent habituellement ou
occasionnement dimanche ce texte va
concerne environ 200000 d'entre eux pour
mettre en place un cadre déégal plus
clair et comportant plus de garantiese
c'est le cas des commerces
d'alimentation qui aujourd'hui selon la
réglementation devrai devaient fermer
leurs portes à midi alors que dans les
petites communes comme dans les grandes
l'heure du déjeuner dominical a
progressivement glissé jusqu'à 13h le
texte qui vous est présenté entérine
cette évolution comme l'avait proposé le
Conseil économique et social et
environnemental c'est le cas aussi des
communes d'intérêt touristiqu dans
lesqueles fréquentation est en Haus
précisément le dimanche désormais à
partir du moment où il existe dans une
commune ou dans une zone touristique une
activité touristique régulière est
soutenue qui justifie l'ouverture des
commerces le dimanche et à partir du
moment où le maire le demande j'y
insiste le préfet pourra autoriser sous
le contrôle de juges administratif tous
les commerces de cette commune de cette
zone à employer des salariés le dimanche
c'est le cas enfin des périmètre d'usage
de consommation exceptionnelle C puces
dont nous avons beaucoup parlé périmètre
caractérisé par des habitudes de
consommation dominicale qui depuis des
années ne pouvaient être satisfait dans
de bonnes conditions les salariés qui
souhaitit travailler pour bénéficier
d'un gain de pouvoir d'achat appréciable
devait ainsi le faire sans contrepartie
et dans un flou juridique total le texte
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale prévoit
désormais que la loi fixe des
contreparties applicables le paiement au
double du travail effectué le dimanche
ou un repos compensateur équivalent à
défaut d'accord collectif fixant
d'autres contreparties vous le voyez
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ces
dérogations sont clairement circonscrit
à des cas précis fondés sur des critères
clairement identifiés c'est assees
strictes conditions et seulement à ces
conditionsl que le texte peut répondre
aux attentes des consommateurs des
touristes des entreprises
tout en offrant des contreparties
sérieuses et des garanties juridiques à
tous les salariés
concernés de façon insidieuse certains
opposants à ce texte ont cependant tenté
d'introduire de la confusion dans les
débats en affectant de redouter la
généralisation progressive à toutes les
communes de la disposition relative aux
communes d'intérêt touristique prétendre
cela c'est d'abord de ne pas tenir
compte des textes qui prévoit au
contraire des critères extrêmement
précis pour juger si une commune
appartient ou non à l'une des deux
catégorie cette proposition de loi ne
modifie en aucune manière les conditions
de classement d'une commune en commune
touristique au sens du Code du travail
tout comme le classement d'une partie de
commune en zone touristique en revanche
elle opère une clarification bienvenue
en rebaptisant désormais les communes
touristiques au sens du code du travail
commune d'intérêt touristique pour
éviter la confusion qui existait entre
les deux dispositifs c'est ensuite ne
pas tenir compte des faits non seulement
il n'y a aujourd'hui que 500 communes
sur les 36000 qui sont concernés par un
tel classement mais surtout le rythme
moyen de progression du nombre de
communes touristiqu est d'environ de 5
par an depuis 10 ans 5 par an depuis 10
ans preuve que les critères du
classement jeun touristique sont
suffisamment claires pour éviter toute
généralisation ces critères sont prévus
par le code du travail il est très clair
que le gouvernement ne les modifiera pas
c'est enfin et surtout tenir pour
quantité négligeable le pouvoir de
décision du maire alors qu'il est en ce
domaine absolument fondamental qui mieux
que le Maire Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs peut savoir qu'il est de
l'intérêt de sa commune d'ouvrir des
commerces le dimanche parce qu'il y a de
laffu clientelle important ce jour-là
qui est mieux placé que le maire pour
évaluer s'il est opportun de demander le
classement d'une commune en zone
touristique qui est plus près du terrain
que le maire pour directement savoir ce
que ces administrés peuvent souhaiter
c'est pourquoi vous n'avez pas lieu de
craindreun transformation d'ù toutes les
communes en commune touristique cette
crainte n'est pas fondée que ce soit
pour demander le classement zone
touristique ou pour appartenir à un puce
si la mairie ne demande rien rien ne
changera c'est une garantie tant pour la
liberté des collectivités locales que
pour l'intérêt des citoyens pourrait-on
en effet sérieusement envisager queun
maire prennent des décisions néfastes
pour sa commune pour ses propres
commerces j'ai occupé ses fonctions de
nombreuses années et je suis comme vous
convaincu du contraire j'ai bien
conscience des interrogations des élus
parisiens
compte tenu du cas particulier de la
capitale puisque c'est le préfet et non
le maire qui aura la responsabilité de
demander le classement en commune
touristique mais pourtant n'est-ce pas
déjà le préfet qui fixe chaque année à
Paris cinq fois par an les dérégations
au repos dominical à Paris la
réglementation en matière de police
administrative et de la responsabilité
de représentant de l'État la dérogation
repos dominicale accorder 5 dimanches
par an revèle donc d'une mesure de
police économique qui de plus
s'accompagne en général de mesures de
police particulière lié à une période de
l'année solld de manifestation
culturelle transport particulier il est
donc logique et pertinent que cette
compétence soit exercée à Paris par le
représentant de l'État j'ai demandé à ce
que l'avis du Conseil de Paris et le cas
échéant des conseils d'arrondissement
concernés par la demande de classement
d'e zone touristique soit prévu dans le
décret en Conseil d'État qui sera pris
en application de la proposition de loi
précisant les modalités de la
consultation relative à l'établissement
des liste des communes d'intérêts
touristique et la délimitation des zones
touristiques d'influence exceptionnelle
ou d'animation culturelle permanente il
n'est pas nécessaire de précéder dans la
loi je le dis en particulier au
sénateurs de Paris qui s'en sont
inquiétés et la loi doit conserver sa
porortter contre aux principes généraux
mais je le répète je prendrai l'avis de
je prendrai l'engagement de de ant la
hautete assemblée que le Conseil de
Paris soit consulté enfin j'entends dire
que ce texte créerait des inégalité
entre les
salariés tout au contraire ce texte
clarifie une situation qui aujourd'hui
est marqué par la confusion voire par
l'injustice cette proposition apporte de
nouvelles garanties elle permet à tous
les salariés qui travaillent le dimanche
dans le cadre des dérogations
administratives individuelles de
bénéficier de partie négocié car le fil
directeur de ce texte c'est bien la
négociation collective qui prend
désormais toute sa place dans les
dérogations au repos dominical la loi du
20 août 2008 portant rénovation de la
démocratie sociale et réforme du temps
de travail aoser de nouvelles bases pour
la négociation collective pour fonder
une légitimité accrue des acteurs de
celles-ci et des accords négociés c'est
dans ce cadrel de règle le majoritaire
renforcé pour les accords et de prise en
compte de l'audience électorale de ceux
qui pourront négocier
qu'intervient cet accent supplémentaire
mis sur la négociation c'est avec des
acccords reposant sur une assise
d'adhésion des salariés plus forte que
donnant plus de place à les négociations
collectives il y aura des négociations
au niveau de la branche comme de
l'entreprise pour tous les commerces
j'ai bien dit tous les commerces
bénéficiant de dérogations
administratives rau Dominica
en vue de la signature d'un accord
relatif au contreparties accordés au
salariés s'agissant des contreparti au
travail du dimanche la proposition de
loi distingue clairement deux types de
situation il existe d'une part les
situations dans lesquelles le travail du
dimanche consti une dérogation de plein
droit et découle des caractéristiques de
l'activité même comme par exemple les
restaurants les hôpitaux les pompes à
essence les ciném ou découlant aussi du
territoire dans lequel sit Perse ce qui
est le cas dans les communes ou dans les
zones touristiques et thermales au sens
du Code du travail dans cette première
situation le travail dominical constitue
une caractéristique intrinseque des
emplois concernés pour ces salariés le
travail du dimanche est une dimension
totalement intégrée de la semaine du
travail une composante normale anticipée
certaine
durable au moment de est prévu comme tel
au moment de l'embauche de l'activité il
revient alors aux dispositions
conventionnelles de fixer le cas échéant
les conditions particulières d'exécution
du contrat de travail assujetti à une
activité
dominicale mais il existe aussi une
nouvelle situation une seconde situation
pour laquelle une autorisation
administrative temporaire et
individuelle
conditionne l'emploi de salarié le
dimanche le travail de salarié le
dimanche remevet dans ce cas un
caractère personnel spécifique il est
donc normal que les salariés concernés
bénéficient de vraies contreparties en
regard de cette situation particulière
tout en préservant la liberté de
négociation des partenaires sociaux s'il
se saisissent de la question je le
rappelle dans ce cas la loi offrira de
nouvelles garanties qui aujourd'hui
n'existent pas c'est le cas également en
matière de volontariat lorsque le
travail dominical résulte une dérogation
administrative
individuelle les opposants à ce texte
craignent de le voir se développer et
par là développer des pression sur le
salarié afin qu'il accepte de renoncer à
son droit au repos dominical notamment
dans les puces je leur répondrai devant
vous que le volontariat n'était
mentionné nulle part dans le code du
travail actuel en matière de travail du
dimanche alors qu'il sera désormais
inscrit noir sur blanc dans cette
proposition de loi j'insisterai enfin
sur la possibilité pour le salarié dans
ce cadre de revenir sur son choix au
terme d'une période
donnée mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous le voyez ce texte
conforte un principe de notre droit le
principe du repos dominical mais il
adapte les dérogations à ce principe en
tenant compte de la diversité de notre
territoire des spécificité local et des
attentes de la très grande majorité des
Français il il appartiendra au maire et
au président des commités de commune de
se saisir si le souhaite de la faculté
qui leur est ainsi
offerte comme l'a prévu l'amendement
mergerie un comité de parlementair de
l'opposition et de la majorité évaluera
d'ici un an la bonne application de ce
texte enveillant tout
particulièrement au respect du principe
général du repos
dominical votre commission des affaires
sociales et je l'en remercie a jugé
satisfaisant l'équilibre qui a été
trouvé après de nombreux mois de débat
le gouvernement se félicite de cet avis
il souhaite que notre discussion
permette d'enrichir encore le débat sans
remettre en cause les équilibres
auxquels nous sommes parvenus je vous
remercie de votre attention merci
Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue madame
de rapporteur de la commission des
affaires
sociales vous avez la parole madame le
rapporteur monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi qui nous
est soumise est le fruit d'une longue
réflexion et de débats animés dont je
comprends parfaitement
légitimité le repos dominical est un
principe affirmé en droit français
depuis
1906 et de toute évidence dans notre
culture le dimanche n'est pas un jour
comme les autres il est par tradition un
jour consacré en priorité à la vie
familiale et aux activités
associative
culturelle sportive ou cultuelle
le principe de repos dominical a
cependant toujours été assorti de
nombreuses dérogations à l'heure
actuelle près de 7 millions et demi de
nos concitoyens travaillent
régulièrement ou occasionnellement le
dimanche certains dans nos services
publics d'autres dans les entreprises
relevant de l'un des 180 cas de
dérogation énuméré par le Code du
travail d'autres encore
dans un établissement titulaire d'une
autorisation
préfectorale certaines dérogations au
repos dominical sont propres au commerce
de détail qui est le seul secteur
d'activité visé par la proposition de
loi ils peuvent cependant ouvrir sans
autorisation du maire sur autorisation
du maire pardon 5 dimanche par an et les
commerces alimentaires peuvent quant à
eux ouvrir tous les dimanches jusqu'à
midi je précise que les règles relatives
au repos dominical qui protègent les
salariés n'empêche nullement un
commerçant d'ouvrir tous les dimanches
s'il le souhaite à condition de ne pas
employer de salariés il peut en revanche
se faire aider de membres de sa
famille certains redoutent que
l'adoption de la proposition de loi
aboutisse à une généralisation du
travail dominical
l'auteur de la proposition de loi notre
collègue député Richard miier a entendu
ses craintes et a fait évoluer son texte
de façon
substantielle il réaffirme le principe
du repos dominical tout en
l'assortissant de trois dérogations
d'ampleur limité qui poursuivent deux
buts
principaux tout d'abord permettre à la
France de mieux répondre aux besoins
particuliers de la clientèle touristique
ensuite adapter notre réglementation au
changement des habitudes de consommation
des habitants des grandes
agglomérations concernant le premier
volet du texte je voudrais souligner que
la réglementation applicable aujourd'hui
dans les communes et les zones
touristiques est d'application complexe
et aboutit parfois à des situation
paradoxale sur une même avenue un
commerce peut-être autorisé à ouvrir
tandis que son voisin lui est obligé de
fermer la solution envisagée par le
texte a le mérite de la simplicité les
commerces de détail situés dans les
communes et les zones touristiques
pourrai ouvrir de plein drroit tous les
dimanches ainsi les touristes qui
passeraient qu'un weekend dans notre
pays pourrai consommer plus facilement
et ces recettes supplémentaires
soutiendraient la croissance et l'emploi
dans les territoires
je voudrais souligner que si la France
effectivement est la première
destination touristique mondiale par le
nombre des visiteurs accueillis elle
n'arrive qu'en 3è position derrière les
États-Unis et l'Espagne concernant les
recettes produites par l'activité
touristique sans augmenter le nombre de
visiteurs nous avons donc une marge de
progression significative pour
développer le chiffre d'affaires et les
emplois liés à l'activité
touristique à l'Assemblée nationale un
débat s'est ouvert sur la question du
nombre de communes concernées par ces
nouvelles règles le groupe
socialiste a affirmé qu'elle
s'appliquerait dans les 6000 communes
classées touristiques au sens du Code du
tourisme en réalité dans la mesure où la
réforme porte sur le code du travail
c'est seulement dans les commune classée
touristique au sens de ce code qu'elle
s'appliquera on en dénombre près de 500
auquels s'ajoute une vingtaine de zones
touristiques à l'avenir de nouvelles
communes pourront demander à être classé
communes touristique mais comme la
demande émanera du maire je fais
confiance à nos élus locaux pour
utiliser cette faculté à
boncien pour toutes raisons le risque de
généralisation du travail dominical qui
est parfois allégué ne me paraît pas
avéré par ailleurs pour mieux protéger
les salariés le texte prévoit que dans
toutes les branches du commerce ou des
contreparties ne sont pas déjà prévu des
négociations devront être engagées entre
les partenaires sociaux je leur fais
confiance pour élaborer au plus près du
terrain les compensations les plus
adaptées et pour que ne se développe des
situations
inéquitables le deuxème volet de la
réforme concneent les périmètres d'usage
de consommation exceptionnelle les puces
qui pourront être délimités dans les
agglomérations de plus d'un millions
d'habitants sur demande du conseil
municipal là où existe un usage de
consommation
dominicale je sais que la création des
puces inquiète certains petits
commerçants qui craignent d'être
pélanisé par l'ouverture dominicale des
grandes enseignes situées en périphérie
de ville le texte comporte cependant
deux gardes-fous que je voudrais
rappeler tout d'abord les grandes
surfaces alimentaires ne sont pas
concernées par la nouvelle
réglementation les petites épiceries de
centre-ville ne sont donc pas menacées
ensuite la création d'un puce ne sera
possible que si un usage de consommation
dominicale est constaté
à Plan de Campagne dans les Bouches du
rô ou à eran dans le Val d'Oise les
magasins ouvrent le dimanche depuis des
décennies le fait de clarifier leur
situation sur le plan juridique ne
changera donc rien à la concurrence
qu'ils font subir au petit
commerce une vingtaine de puces pourrait
être constitué mais aucun dans la région
lyonnaise dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
où on n'y a pas constaté d'usage de
consommation dominicale dans
l'agglomération lilloise la création de
puces pourrait en revanche aider les
commerces à faire face le dimanche à la
concurrence des magasins
Belges la création des puces répond aux
nouvelles habitudes de consommation des
habitants des grandes
agglomérations comme les zones
commerciales y sont situées en
périphérie les clients n'ont pas
toujours le temps de s'y rendre en
semaine et les magasins sont saturés le
samedi ce qui n'est attrayant ni pour
les clients ni pour les salariés dont
les conditions de travail sont fortement
dégradées l'ouverture dominicale permet
d'étaler les achats dans le temps et
facilite ainsi la vie de
chacun la proposition de loi précise que
les salariés travaillant le dimanche
dans les puces devront être volontaires
et et qu'ils bénéficieront de
contreparties définies en priorité par
voie d'accord collec
l'Assemblée nationale a utilement
précisé comment un salarié qui a donné
son accord pour travailler le dimanche
pourra ultérieurement revenir sur son
choix cette possibilité de réversibilité
est une garantie importante en effet si
le travail dominical peut convenir à
certaines étapes de la vie par exemple
pour quelqu'un qui poursuit des études
et recherche un emploi à temps partiel
il peut en
se révéler très contraignant à d'autres
périodes par exemple pour un couple qui
souhaite passer du temps avec ses enfant
en
basâge la trème mesure proposée par le
texte est plus ponctuelle elle consiste
à autoriser les commerces de détail
alimentaires à ouvrir jusqu'à 13h au
lieu de midi cet ajustement me semble
conforme à l'évolution des modes de vie
des
Français Commission a estimé que le
texte élaboré par l'Assemblée nationale
était équilibré et a donc adopté sans
modification à l'issu d'un débat dont je
tiens à souligner la qualité et qui a
permis à chacun d'exprimer ses
convictions pour évaluer l'impact du
texte un comité de suivi composé de six
parlementaires issu pour la moitié de la
majorité et pour moitié de l'opposition
va être mise en place
dans un an il remettra un rapport qui
dressera un premier bilan et il nous
appartiendra d'entirer les conséquences
et d'apporter le cas échéant les
correctifs
nécessaires je voudrais vous dire en
conclusion je pense sincèrement que l'on
ne se trompe jamais à donner plus de
liberté à nos
concitoyens à
condition que la loi fixe un cadre
précis qui évite les dérives et les
abus je pense que le texte mûement
réfléchi qui nous est soumis répond à
ces critères et je vous propose donc de
l'adopter afin de mieux répondre aux
attentes de beaucoup de consommateurs et
de certains salariés et de soutenir le
secteur du commerce déjà bien mal par la
crise je vous
remercie merci madame le
rapporteur madame la
présidenteésident avec l'autorisation de
la Commission et pour clarifier nos
débats je souhaite la disjonction de la
discussion commune des amendements de
suppression partielle de l'article 2 il
s'agit d'abord de l'amendement numéro 9
de Madame Le Texier qui propose de
supprimer le par paragraphe 2 et met en
discussion 85 amendements il s'agit
aussi des amendements 25 et 99 déposés
respectivement par les groupes
socialistes et CRC SPG qui maintiennent
53 amendements en discussion commune
pour la clarté et une meilleure
compréhension de nos débats il sera plus
aisé d'avoir à discuter ensemble des
séries plus réduite d'amendements je
pense que le gouvernement n'y verra pas
d'inconvénient je vous remercie monsieur
le président
le
gouvernement le gouvernement est tout à
fait favorable à cette proposition
monsieur le Président je mes chers
collègues je vrais rappeler que c'est
l'application de l'article
49 alinéa 2 de notre nouveau
règlement donc par référence donc ceux
qui sont favorables le manifeste en
levant la
main avis
contraire
adopté merci donc la
disjonction est
ordonnée j'indique au Sénat que compte
tenu de l'organisation du débat décidé
par la Conférence des Présidents des
temps de paroles dont disposent les
groupes pour cette discussion sont les
suivants groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire 39 minutes groupe socialiste
32 minutes groupe de l'Union centriste
16 minutes groupe communiste républicain
citoyens sénateur du Parti de Gauche 15
minutes groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen 13
minutes réunion administrative des
sénateur de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe 5 minutes dans la suite
de notre discussion générale la parole
est au président Nicolas Abou pour le
groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
d'abord je voudrais d'un mot remercier
notre excellente collègue madame Le
Texier d'avoir eu la gentillesse
d'accepté de modifier l'ordre de passage
des orateurs à la
tribune mes chers collègues que de
précaution dans l'intitulé de cette
proposition de loi des précautions bien
compréhensibles quand on sait à quel
point le débat
a été jusqu'ici
passionnel mais cette passion à mon avis
ne se justifie pas ou en tous les cas ne
se justifie plus la grogne de certains
dans un premier
temps nous paraît en
décalage avec la nature éminemment
technique et bien peu révolutionnaire de
la proposition qui nous est
soumise alors mes chers collègues
dépassionnons dépassionnons le débat et
regardons en face ce qui nous est
soumis ce texte
n'est ni la panacée promise ni le poison
dénoncé par les uns ou les autres que
nous proposons au juste principalement
deux
choses d'assouplir les conditions
d'octroit de l'une des dérogations déjà
existantes au repos dominical celle
relative à certaines communes et zones
touristiques ou
thermales deuxièmement de créer une
possibilité deog repos dominical au sein
des unités urbaines de plus d'un million
d'habitants concernant la première
disposition il s'agit d'une mesure
destinée à soutenir la croissance et
l'emploi dans le secteur du tourisme un
secteur pour lequel il n'est pas
contesté ni contestable que des gains
sont possibles la France n'est-elle pas
chacun le sait le pays qui accueille le
plus de
touristes nous verrons s'agissant
maintenant de la création des périmètres
d'usage de consommation exceptionnelle
au sein des grandes unités urbaines les
fameux pu disons les choses clairement
il est essentiellement question de
régulariser des anomalies
existantes on a on peut le voir comme ça
nous en
reparlerons nous verrons cela on a
évoqué le cas de Plan de Campagne dans
les Bouches du rond ou des ran dans le
valdoise plus
anecdotique le Tex autorise les comm
détail alimentaire à ouvrir jusqu'à 13h
le ministre nous disait faut prendre en
compte la façon dont les choses
fonctionnent au
quotidien 13h au lieu de midi c'est pas
et ce afin d'adapter la dérogation de
droit au mode de vie actuel je le
confirme ce texte s'il vous plaît ce
texte réaffirme simplement le principe
du repos dominical mais cette
réaffirmation ne change rien chacun bien
conscience au droits positifs il s'agit
là d'un texte de
simplification c'est uniquement en tant
qu'il permettra de régulariser et
d'aplanir un certain nombre de
situations aussi quels sont les
véritables interrogations posées elles
sont à nos yeux au nombre de trois
première question majeure posée par ce
texte après son adoption que deviendra
le champ des dérogations au repos
dominical c'est l'argument plus fort
pour ceux qui pour s'y opposer nous
évoquent toujours le fameux argument de
la pente glissante cette proposition
ouvrirait une brèche qui conduirait de
fait la dérogation à devenir la règle et
le principe
l'exception il y a là une peur qui nous
paraît en l'occurrence
irrationnelle mais non les pu ne
concerneront qu'un très petit nombre de
secteurs bien
identifiés quant à la mesure de article
L 31 32-25 le gouvernement a donné de
CNE gag qu'elle ne s'appliquerait qu'à
un nombre restreint de commune
touristique ce qui est confirmé dans le
texte même tel qu'issu des travaux de
l'Assemblée nationale les communes
concernées ne seront pas toutes les
commune visé par le Code du Tourisme le
ministre nous l'a rappelé mais bien
celle désignée par le code du travail et
qualifié de commune d'intérêt
touristique la différence est de taille
dans ces conditions l'effet de contagion
est hautement
improbable deuxème question clé soulevée
par la proposition de loi quelle
compensation au travail
dominical le code du travail ne pose
aucun principe de compensation d'or
publi qui s'appliquerait à toutes les
dérogations ce vide législatif conduit
un état de droit extrêmement
disparat les compensations auxquelles
les salariés ont droit peuvent varier du
tout au tout en fonction de la
dérogation dont bénéficie leur employeur
tout dépend donc des dispositions
législatives et conventions collectives
applicables cependant force de constater
que le texte améliore le régime des
compensations sans le
chambouler surtout tel qu'il ressort des
travaux de nos collègues
députés d'abord chacun le constate
l'article 1er garanti de bien meilleur
compensation que celle existante jusque
à maintenant pour les C dimanches
ouverts par le maire
ensuite l'article 2 garantit qu'en
l'absence d'accord collectif les
salariés dominicaux des périmètres
d'usage de consommation exceptionnelle
bénéficieront au minimum d'un salaire
doublé et d'un repos compensateur en
temps enfin et c'est fondamental
l'Assemblée nationale a posé le principe
d'une protection conventionnelle
transversale et minimale en imposant aux
partenaires sociaux de négocier sur le
régime de compensation au travail
dominical partout où des dérogations
sont applicables encore une fois en
matière de compensation au travail
dominical ce texte n'est pas la panacée
mais nous apporte des avané certaines et
j'en arrive au troisème enjeu
sous-jacant au texte qui n'est plus un
enjeu législatif mais exclusivement
gouvernemental si vous le permettez il
s'agit de savoir si l'administration se
donnera les moyens d'assurer
l'application de ce texte tel qu'elle le
devrait parce que la contrepartie à la
régularisation à laquelle il nous est
proposé de procéder doit être un
engagement ferme du gouvernement
d'organiser des poursuites systématiques
contre les contevenants à
venir si l'on régularise et je reprends
la remarque de notre collègue Michel si
l'on régularise aujourd'hui ce que l'on
a toléré jusqu'ici ça n'est pas pour
laisser se reconstituer de nouvelles
poches d'illégalité et bien non
autrement dit cette régularisation doit
être la dernière et si l'on ouvre les
magasins le dimanche il alors alors il
faudra aussi mettre en place un contrôle
par l'inspection du travail le dimanche
c'est le parallélisme qui l'exige vous
l'avez compris monsieur le ministre s'il
vous plaît pour toutes les raisons que
je viens de développer et sous réserve
des assurances que vous pourrez nous
fournir en matière d'application du
texte et parce qu'il détermine un point
d'équilibre acceptable
entre ordre et liberté la majorité des
membres du groupe de l'Union centriste
est prête à soutenir cette
proposition merci monsieur le
Président la parole est à Madame rmonde
Le Texier pour le groupe
socialiste
bonjour
madame vous avez la parole chers
collègues monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues parfois la loi impacte le
quotidien de nos concitoyens jusqu'à en
changer des aspects fondamentaux et le
texte sur le travail le dimanche en est
un exemple
frappant adopté à l'Assemblée nationale
à une courte majorité mercredi dernier
ce texte que nous examinons à partir
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas comme voudrait
le faire croire le gouvernement un
simple toilettage technique des
dérogations autorisant le travail le
dimanche nous en sommes bien loin hélas
en
France le travail dominical est déjà une
réalité si on additionne les dérogations
autorisant le travail le dimanche au
titre de l'intérêt général
transport et hôpitaux par exemple les
dérogations au motif de l'intérêt
économique secteur touristique ou encore
les dérogations exceptionnelles que les
maires peuvent accorder au nombre de 5
par an ce sont 7 millions et demi de
Français qui travaillent déjà le
dimanche soit près de un salarié sur 3
en Europe nous sommes ainsi dans la
fourchette haute tandis que nous sommes
3è s'agissant du travail le moyenne
entre le samedi et le dimanche et
premier lorsqu'il s'agit seulement du
travail le samedi nous sommes donc bien
loin des stéréotypes qui voudrai que les
Français travaillent moins que les
autres alors pourquoi ce texte par ces
temps de crise le gouvernement avance un
argument qui raisonne dans les esprits
l'extension du travail le dimanche
produirait de la croissance et des
emplois en changeant les conditions de
l'offre la systématisation du travail le
dimanche devrait libérer une partie de
l'épargne jusqu'ici bloqué et l'orienter
vers la consommation produisant ainsi de
la richesse et des emplois raisonnement
séduisant mais économiquement il ne
tient pas tout d'abord parce que
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
génère des bonus de consommation pour
que l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
génère des bonus de consommation il
faudrait qu'il y ait actuellement des
lacunes dans l'offre des goulots
d'étranglement qui réduiraient notre
capacité à consommer ce n'est pas le cas
au contraire les conditions de l'offre
sont excellentes en France et d'ailleurs
TR français sur qu considèrent que le
temps d'ouverture des magasins est
suffisant ensuite comme l'ont révélé
plusieurs études l'ouverture le dimanche
ne produit pas d'activité économique
supplémentaire mais uniquement un
transfert d'activité au lieu de
consommer en semaine nous consommerons
le dimanche l'étude du CREDOC précise
que l'essentiel des ventes réalisé le
dimanche corresp au transfert des ventes
initialement réalisé les autres jours de
la semaine enfin pour qu'il y ait
davantage de consommation il faudrait
qu'il y ait plus d'argent disponible
mais quand on a un reste à vivre
hebdomadaire de 50 € qu'on le dépense en
semaine ou le dimanche on a toujours que
50 € pour boucler la semaine de plus en
période de crise l'épargne tend à se
contracter elle ne sert pas à consommer
mais à tenir en cas de coup dur il n'est
pas nécessaire d'avoir fait HC pour
comprendre qu'en pleine crise alors que
le chômage explose les Français ne ne
vont pas casser leur plan d'Épagne leur
codvi ou leur badeline pour aller
s'acheter une nouvelle télé simplement
parce que Dary est ouvert le dimanche
quant à la
création quant à la création d'emplois
qu'on nous fait miroiter c'est une
contre vérité il est établi que s'il y
aura bien des emplois créés dans les
grands centres commerciaux pour
l'ouverture le dimanche ces emplois
créés seront moins nombreux
que les emplois détruits dans le petit
commerce dans un article publié il y a
quelques mois une soixantaine de députés
de la majorité précisait qu'en matière
de travail dominical pour un emploi créé
dans la grande distribution il y a trois
emplois qui sont détruit dans le
commerce de détail mieux encore une
autre étude estimé que plus de 200000
emplois seraient détruits en cas de
généralisation de l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche monsieur le
ministre mes chers collèues afin d'être
tout à fait crédible à vos yeux je tiens
à vous préciser que ces chiffres sans
appel 200000 emplois détruit en cas de
généralisation du travail du dimanche
sont des chiffres fournis par votre
majorité puisqu'ils proviennent d'une
étude commandée en 2006 par le ministre
du Commerce d'Alor monsieur Renault
duutreil puisquil n'y a aucun bénéfice à
attendre de l'extension d'ouverture le
dimanche tant pour l'économie que pour
l'emploi comment expliquer que ce
gouvernement ne cesse d'y pousser
serait-ce parce qu'il s'agit d'une
promesse de campagne du candidat Sarkozi
et que le président refuse de lâcher
prise en ver et contre tout bon sens
serait-ce parce qu'il s'agit en fait de
légaliser des pratiques illégales et
pérennes dans le seul but de satisfaire
des intérêts particuliers serait-ce
parce qu'il s'agit purement et
simplement d'une loi d'amnistie pour les
commerces qui ouvrent le dimanche depuis
des années au mépris de
l'interdiction sans doute un peu tout
cela mais ce texte de lobbying ce texte
d'acharnement idéologique qui n'était en
rien nécessaire ne va pas juste
satisfaire quelques intérêts
particuliers en quête de main d'œuvre
moins cher non il va surtout aggraver la
situation des salariés et rapidement
abîmer le vivre ensemble des Français ce
texte va aggraver la situation des
salariés car pour une large partie
d'entre
le travail dominical va devenir
obligatoire et sans
contrepartie en effet dans les vill dit
d'intérêt touristique comprenant au
minimum toutes les grandes villes de
France et donc la majorité des Français
tous les salariés de tous les commerces
devront travailler le dimanche ce ne
sera pas sur la base du volontariat ce
sera une obligation contractuelle car
l'ouverture de ces commerces deviendra
de droit et parce que l'ouverture
Dominique il sera de droit il n'y aura
ni doublement de salaire ni jour de
repos compensateur et c'est déjà le cas
j'en veux pour preuve l'arrêt de la Cour
de cassation du 31 janvier 2009 qui a
débouté un salarié travaillant le
dimanche dans un magasin d'ameublement
sans compensation financière la Cour a
estimé qu'au motif que le magasin était
habituellement ouvert le dimanche depuis
l'amendement de Bré loi de janvier 2008
et le salarié travaillant habituellement
le dimanche le dimanche est un jour
comme les autres qui n'ouvre pas droit à
compensation ne pas dire cela clairement
aux salariés qui comptent sur le travail
dominical pour boucler un budget
impossible c'est une
malhonnêteté certes dans les périmètres
urbains de consommation exceptionnel les
puces qui ne s'appliqueront qu'au grands
complexes commerciaux à la périphérie de
Paris et Lille les salariés seront en
droit de refuser de travailler le
dimanche mais dans les fites qui peut
croire que ces salariés auront le choix
connaissant les rapports de
subordination qui régissent le monde du
salariat peut-on croire que ces
travailleurs prendront le risque d'aller
de dire de rejoindre les millions de
chômeurs en refusant de travailler le
dimanche quand leur employeur le leur
demandera le Gouvernement présente ce
texte comme un texte uniquement
technique ne portant que sur des aspects
juridiques car il sait bien que si ce
texte devait se révéler pour ce qu'il
est c'est-à-dire un texte bouleversant
de fond en comble notre façon de vivre
il n'aurait aucune chance de passer
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas par hasard si
c'est la 4e version de ce texte qui est
présenté au Parlement en un an les trois
premières versions ayant été repoussées
fermement ce n'est pas par hasard que ce
texte est débattu ici fin juillet quand
toute la France est en vacances vous
vous savez pertinemment que si les
Français n'étaient pas à la plage ils
seraient dans la rue ce n'est pas par
hasard mais c'est à raison que nombre de
nos collègues de la majorité ose rejeter
ce texte publiquement et ceux qui le
condamnent en coulisse sont encore plus
nombreux vous savez bien qu'avec ce
texte vous manipulez un bâton de
dynamite dont la mèche est d'ors etj
déjà allumé nous le disons sans détour à
chaque parlementaire de la majorité avec
toutes ces nouvelles dérogations au
repos dominical le travail le dimanche
sera banalisé non seulement le dimanche
va devenir un jour travailler comme les
autres mais un jour comme les autres
tout court vous le savez comme nous
c'est bien là l'enjeu essentiel de ce
texte transformer le dimanche en un jour
comme les autres pour changer de modèle
de société le problème du gouvernement
c'est que les Français sont contre ce
recul contre cette rétrogradation
sociétale qu'ils n'en veulent pas de
votre société de la consommation totale
et du travail nonstop ce sont des pans
entiers de notre façon de vivre
collectivement et individuellement qui
repose largement sur ce temps disponible
que nous offre le dimanche depuis la loi
1906 le dimanche est au cœur du pacte
social national le dimanche c'est ce que
les Français ont en commun ce n'est pas
non plus un hasard si 85 % des Français
estiment aujourd'hui que le dimanche est
un jour fondamental pour la vie de
famille sportive culturelle ou
spirituelle et que c'est à ce titre qu'
doit rester un jour de repos pour le
plus grand nombre pour 85 % des Français
de droite ou de gauche jeune ou vieux
riche ou pauvre croyant ou até vivant en
couple ou célibataire la famille les
amis les loisirs les activités
culturelles l'engagement associatif
l'épanouissement personnel le lien
social et la transmission entre les
générations le dimanche c'est d'abord
cela privz les
Français priver les Français de ce
moment commun c'est organiser siamment
le délitement notre société dans son
ensemble et de la cellule familiale en
particulier aucun de nous aucun de vous
ne peut laisser faire ça dans son
discours de versaill le président
Sarkozi a tenu à s'inscrire dans
l'héritage du programme du Conseil
National de la Résistance c'est pour le
moins étonnant alors que le Conseil
National de la Résistance défendait le
droit au repos le texte sur le travail
du dimanche fait disparaître le repos
commun des travailleurs alors que le
Conseil National de la Résistance
prenait la garantie d'un niveau de
salaire et de traitement qui assure à
chaque travailleur et à la famille la
sécurité la dignité et la possibilité
d'une vie pleinement humaine ce texte
nous dit que les Français doivent aller
travailler le dimanche pour espérer
compenser leur trop faible niveau de
salaire alors que le Conseil National de
la Résistance demandait la sécurité de
l'emploi la réglementation des
conditions d'embauche et de licenciement
ce texte va favoriser la précarité des
salariés qui ne pourront refuser de
travailler le dimanche mais ce n'est pas
nouveau Donis Kessler ancien
vice-président du Medef grand patron
président du 5e groupe d'assurance
mondiale déclarait voici quelques temps
dans une interview au magazine challenge
la liste des réformes du
gouvernement peut donner une impression
de patchwork personne n'arrive à voir la
logique mais à y regarder de plus près
on constate qu'il y a une profonde unité
à ce programme ambitieux la liste des
réformes c'est simple prenez tout ce qui
a été mis en place entre 1944 et
1952 sans exception elle est là il
s'agit aujourd'hui de sortir de
1945 et de défaire méthodiquement le
programme du Conseil National de la
Résistance fin de
citation le texte sur le travail
dominical est clairement la dernière
étape en date de la casse du droit du
travail qui est opéré depuis 3 ans et à
force de casser le droit du travail ce
sont les fondements de notre société que
l'on détruit le repos du dimanche comme
moment commun de tous les Français est
le plus visible de ces fondements
améliorer les conditions de vie de nos
concitoyens est au centre de notre
engagement politique pour nous
précariser toujours plus les
travailleurs ce ne peut pas être un
projet de société travailleurs la loi
doit
s'inscrire la loi doit s'inscrire dans
la défense de l'intérêt
général ce texte adné l'antithèse
parfaite les parlementaires socialistes
s'y opposeront de toute leurs
forces la parole est maintenant madame
Isabelle Pasquet pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen sénateur
du Parti de
Gauche vous avez la parole mes chers
collègu
ça
comm monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la procédure
utilisée par le gouvernement pour ce
texte sera abordée par ma collègue aussi
je ne m attarderaiit pas sinon pour
insister sur son caractère inapproprié
et en l'espèce uniquement destiné à
masquer au français et singulièrement au
salariés les vraies intentions du
législateur la banalisation du travail
du
dimanche je le sais et qui ne le saurait
pas d'ailleurs après une telle campagne
de promotion le seul et unique objectif
du gouvernement en faisant passer ce
texte en plein été avec la procédure
accélérée c'est de réaffirmer le
principe du du repos dominical c'est
dans le titre même du texte déposé par
Monsieur miier de son Dee texte puisque
le premier avait paru tellement abouti
en terme de réponse économique comme en
terme de réponse sociale aux légitimes
inquiétudes des Français que même au
sein de l'UMP il s'en était trouvé et
pas moindre pour bouder le texte voire
même
l'hémicycle mais si nous nous sommes
réjouis que cette première mouture soit
retoquer nous n'avions pas d'illusion
sur l'acharnement du gouvernement à
vouloir de toute urgence réaffirmer le
principe du repos dominical pour mieux
le contourner car il s'agit là d'un
véritable enjeu sociétal un enjeu de
classe c'est un enjeu pour le modèle
social de notre pays et son droit du
travail dont Monsieur sarzi vente les
mérites modérateur sur les effets de la
crise mais qu'on nous demande de
démanteler au nom du libéralisme débridé
de la liberté du renard dans le
poulailler alors que la crise dans
laquelle nous a entraîné l'incroyable
cécité dont vous avez fait preuve
vis-à-vis de la financiarisation de
l'économie et dont vous continuez à
faire preuve se traduit désormais par
des dizaines de milliers de chômeurs
supplémentaires tous les mois des
centaines de milliers sont attendus à la
fin de l'année
alors que la consommation des ménages a
fortement chuté par la conjonction d'une
bulle spéculative de l'immobilier et de
la baisse de la part des salaires dans
la valeur
ajoutée alors que les perspectives
offertes à notre jeunesse au sortir du
baccalauréat ou même des filières
universitaires ce Taris au point que les
stages rémunérés promus par Monsieur
Frédéric Lefèvre deviennent la norme
contrairement aux affirmations contenues
dans l'exposé des motif de la loi qui
stipulit il convient de veiller à ce que
les stages ne soient utilisés que pour
les besoins de la formation des jeunes
et combattre les abus induisant une
utilisation des stagiaires comme des
faux salariés payés en dessous du SMIC
c'est pourquoi il faut donc réserver les
stages uniquement au cursus pédagogique
et les interdire en dehors en effet dans
les autres situations il pourrait être
recouru à la formation professionnelle
ou un contrat de travail fin de citation
l'urgence serait donc au travail du
dimanche pour rendre du charme à nos
villes comme à Paris de l'attractivité à
nos zones
commerciales du droit dans les zones
deendroit comme à Plan de Campagne de la
compétitivité à nos entreprises et de
l'appétit au consommateurs à défaut de
pouvoir
d'achat concernant le
tourisme première destination
touristique au monde la France
serurait-elle acculé à user des mêmes
expédient que baragne ou Abou Dhabi que
Cancun ou Las Vegas pour attirer le
chalent le patrimoine architectural et
culturel de notre pays son patrimoine
historique et géographique industriel
eologique et gastronomique sont pourtant
en tête des raisons invoquées par les
personnes qui séjourent dans notre pays
parce que leur séjour ne se cantonne pas
à une journée que je sache ils ne
viennent pas que le dimanche ils peuvent
aussi profitez donc pour fréquenter les
artères commerçantes et pour ce qui
concerne tourisme de transit croisière
correspondance aérienn ou ferroviaire
les dispositifs régissant ces zones
spécifiques autorisent déjà l'ouverture
dominicale permettez d'ailleurs que je
m'interroge sur un argument invoqué par
le Président de la République censé
démontrer l'anachronisme de la fermeture
dominicale des commerces dans un pays
moderne Monsieur S
a dû lui-même prendre son téléphone pour
faire ouvrir les magasins afin de
permettre au couple présidentiel
états-uniens de faire quelques emples
pendant leur visite officielle à Paris
on peut et Monsieur sarcosi peut
s'interroger sur la pertinence de notre
arsenal législatif sur son adaptation à
nos pratiques contemporaines dans dans
de nombreux domaines il paraît pourtant
tout à fait inconcevable que le chef de
l'État en charge plus que tout autre du
respect de nos institutions s'estime
autorisé à exiger de personnes privées
d'enfreindre la loi fus pour faire
plaisir à un ami les questions des
frontières ne pas dépasser sembl ici
dépasser l'entendement commun notons par
ailleurs que cette ouverture de commerce
par la grâce présidentielle un jour de
fermeture habituelle résulte d'abord
d'impératif de
sécurité imaginons un instant que le
couple
Obama fasse ses courses pendant les
soldes au milieu d'une ftitude
empressée impensable e-il fallu alors
fermer ces magasins le temps nécessaire
CQFD l'argument est
irrecevable pour conserver l'illusion
que le repos dominical reste la règle et
que le travail ce même jour le serait à
titre dérogatoire et donc exceptionnel
on nous annonce que les zones touchées
par le dispositif seraient au nombre de
500 environ plus précisément 497 et
qu'une généralisation à la quasittalité
de notre territoire ne serait qu'une
interprétation abusive de quelques
farfelu voire carrément une invention au
caractère bassement politicien mais
qu'en est-il vraiment les zones
désignées comme touristiques qui
bénéficieront donc de la possibilité
d'ouvrir le dimanche capteront de la
clientèle disons mécaniquement et les
communes voisines sous la pression des
acteurs économique souhaiteront entrer
dans le dispositif encore une fois au
nom de la concurrence on verra s'étendre
les zones touristiques et encore une
fois ce sont les salariés qui en feront
les frais comment pourrait-il en être
autrement dans ces pays comme le nôtre
qui cumule un tel patrimoine dans chacun
de ces
départements s'agissant des puces
périmètres d'usage et de consommation
exceptionnel alors à propos d'égalité de
droit et de devoir devant la loi forcez
de constater que nous construisons des
usines à gaz qui s'en éloigne de plus en
plus sans autre raison que l'intérêt
bien compris de quelques privilégiés
ainsi à Lyon concerné a priori à double
titre celui du tourisme et plus
prosaïquement celui des périmètres
d'usage et de consommation
exceptionnelle parce que c'est une une
agglomération de plus de 2 millions
d'habitants Lyon se trouve exclu du
dispositif puisqu'il n'existe pas
d'usage de consommation le samedi et le
dimanche apparemment nous n'allons pas
sur nos bancs fustiger des élus qui ont
choisi de ne pas être demandeur pour
leur commune de travailler le dimanche
par contre parmi ses élus il se trouvent
des partisans de cette loi mais pas
appli mais applicable aux autres
c'est-à-dire en dehors de leur
circonscription électorale cela démontre
bien s'il en était besoin que l'égalité
des citoyens l'égalité des salariés
d'une même branche professionnel d'une
même enseigne ne sont pas respectés mais
je ne peux pas parler des pu sans sans
évoquer l'affaire de Plan de
Campagne puisque c'est dans mon
département puisque c'est de là que part
toute l'histoire si on peut dire
ainsi je ne vais pas revenir sur la
genèse de ce qui a fait ce qui
aujourd'hui une des plus grandes zones
commerciales d'Europe je ne vais pas
revenir sur 43 ans de dérogation
d'ouverture illégal de conflit de
procédures judiciaires et cetera je vais
simple faire un petit rappel le 24
janvier
2007 des partenaires sociaux se sont
réunis sous l'gides du préfet de région
pour trouver un accord de méthode
qualifié de particulièrement positif à
l'époque pour un retour progressif au
droit commun à la légalité il faut
préciser d'ailleurs que cet accord fait
suite à un conflit activé autour d'un
jugement rendu par le tribunal
administratif de Marseille dénonçant
l'arrêté profectorale pour l'ouverture
domic de certaines enseigne alors cet
accord envisageait la nécessaire
modernisation de la zone afin de
permettre la diversification de ses
activités de sa sécurisation et de son
accessibilité il prévoyait également des
contreparties à négocier avec différents
interlocuteurs concernés état région
Conseil Général
propriétaire pour que les entreprises ne
soient pas pénalisées que les emplois
puissent être maintenus révision des
loyers à allisement de la taxe
professionnelle et de la taxe foncière
entre autres seulle la Communauté du
Pays d'X a émis un avis
favorable les partenaires sociaux ayant
constaté le défaut d'engagement de
l'État et des collectivités locales sur
un programme précis pouvant garantir la
pérenité de la zone de plan de campagne
sur le plan social et le plan économique
ont donc mis fin à l'accord de méthode
du 24 janvier 2007 conformément à ses
dispositions il convient alors d'un
nouvel accord le 19 juillet 2007 sur un
retour au droit commun dans un délai
expirant le 30 juin
2008 mais depuis malheureusement rien
n'a été fait la seule réponse apportée à
ce jour aux partenaires sociaux et la
proposition de loi de monsieur
miier qui soit dit en passant lui a
coûté son canton qui me fait dire que ce
le travail du dimanche peêtre pas
partagé par la
majorité qui vise à légaliser
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
mais surtout
surtout qui met fin à tout espoir de
trouver un consensus entre les salariés
et les chefs d'entreprises les usagers
et les habitants de la zone sans oublier
bien sûr les collectivités territoriales
concernées petite précision il ne reste
plus que 700 salariés à régulariser sur
7000 don 100 étudiants suite à l'AM
demande de Madame Debray concernant les
magasins d'ameublement donc je
m'interroge et on voit bien que le
problème que veut régler la majorité est
ailleurs monsieur miier a mené une
campagnne assarné contre les
organisations syndicales qui veulent
faire respecter la
loi aujourd'hui il nous demande en
réalité de légiférer pour légaliser une
zone de non droit où l'État a
complètement démissionné de ses missions
en matière de permis de construire par
exemple de grand anciennes sont installé
sans déposer de demande d'autres ont
déclaré la construction de bâtiments à
usage d'entrepôt qui se sont transformés
en sur en surface de vente sans
autorisation pour ce qui est de la
sécurité aucun plan d'évacuation ni même
de secours ne peut-être mise en œuvre un
jour de grande affluence un rapport de
la DDE montre qu'il faut 1h30 pour
traverser la zone il n'y a pas la
possibilité de faire atterrir un
hélicoptère voilà ce qui'est la réalité
de plan campagne et la proposition de
loi de Monsieur miier n'apporte aucune
solution je voudrais dire aussi qu'en
ces temps où la majorité semble
découvrir que le développement pour être
véritablement durable a besoin de toute
autre chose que de
slogans pour ça je vous renvoie au débat
sur le connais sur l'environnement
encourager le développement de ce type
de zone même les États-uniens en
revienneent c'est aller à l'encontre des
besoins des réponses que nous devrions
apporter collectivement aux menaces qui
pèsent sur notre planète car n'oublions
pas qu'avec le
développement de l'activité commerciale
le dimanche s'ajoute la logistique des
heures d'embouteillage des hectares de
parking des tonnes d'emballage des
travailleurs souspayés que de gaspillage
que de contreesens à l'avenir de
l'humanité et maintenant le dimanche
pour régulariser une situation de fait
et au nom de quoi pour répondre
nouvelles habitudes de consomm alors que
des études ont montré que des habitudes
de consommation changent très vite pour
éviter que la précarité qui est le lot
de la majorité des salariés du commerce
ne rime définitivement avec travailleurs
pauvres et surtout pour en finir avec
cette vieille conquête sociale et
collective du repos hebdomadaire que le
patronat n'avait jusqu'à présent pas
réussi à
contourner après la Commission
européenne qui s'accorde sur la semaine
de travail de 48 he après notre
gouvernement qui estime plausible de
retarder l'âge de départ la retraite
jusqu'à 67 ans nous devrions aussi nous
accorder sur la mise à mort du repos
hebdomadaire pour les sénateurs de notre
groupe comme ce fut le cas l'Assemblée
nationale pour nos collègues c'est non
et nous continuons à ferrailler contre
cette mesure jusqu'au Conseil
constitutionnel s'il le
faut bonjour
madame
la parole est à notre collègue Monsieur
François
Fortassin bonjour
François très
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues il y a plus d'un siècle
à savoir le 13 juillet 1906 la loi
sarien du nom du président du conseil de
l'époque
instaurer de façon
définitive le repos
hebdomadaire le
dimanche c'était
indiscutablement une loi
progressiste et elle permit au
gouvernement de
l'époque apaiser les tensions sociales
mais aussi les tensions
religieuses moins d'un an après la
séparation de l'Église de l'État il
s'agissait d'une
loi
républicaine humaniste et
laïque
aujourd'hui ces grands principes sont
foulés aux
pied
comme d'autres lois fondatrices de la
République cette loi donc est toujours
en vigueur même s'il y a eu de très
nombreuses
dérogations qui sont qui ont été accepté
au fil du temps voilà
qu'aujourd'hui le président de la
République et son gouvernement veulent
passer en force au cœur de l'été un
moment où les Français ont sans doute
d'autres préoccupations que le travail
législatif mais monsieur le ministre ne
vous inquiétez pas nous sommes là pour
les réveiller à l'heure de la
sieste alors l'heure des vèbres il
s'agit de remettre en
cause de façon très
grave l'un des piliers de notre vivre
ensemble la journée du dimanche jour de
repos
chacun peut se consacrer à ses activités
aux activités de son choix qu'ell soi
familial sportive associative et
culturelle religieuse
ou et cetera ou
culturel et je dois
dire qu'on est en train aussi de mettre
à mal un grand principe et ça quel que
soit nos sensibilités nous devons y
veiller
l'ensemble la plus grande partie des
travailleurs du
commerce que ce soit dans la grande
distribution ou le petit
commerce sont des gens qui ont des
salaires relativement
modeste l'avantage qu'ils ont par
rapport à des gens qui ont des
responsabilités très importantes c'est
qui peuvent se consacrer à une vie
familiale
harmonieuse et ça vous allez le
casser c'est
votre mon cher collègue c'est votre
analyse on peut on peut fort bien ne pas
la partager
ensuite
croire que parce que on supprimera
le repos du
dimanche on va doperer le commerce il
faudra qu'on
mexlique comment on va améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat par un coup de baguette
magique enfin il y a parfois monsieur le
ministre certaines ironies du sort vous
étiez il y a pas si longtemps dans un
autre ministère
ou pour faire
passer
le la fermeture des les écoles le samedi
vous nous avez vous nous avez expliqué
qu'il fallait que bien entendu en plus
du dimanche les enfants est un jour de
repos
supplémentaire certes vous avez
changé de ministère mais que je Sange il
est pas obligatoire que vous changeiez
de
conviction
bon la réalité on est dans un système
quand même de grande confusion et on va
créer des disparités on va rallumer des
guerres qui n'ont pas lieu d'être est-ce
que vous croyez très sincèrement
Mesdames et
Messieurs que ceux qui travaillent dans
le petit commerce auront véritablement
le
choix moi j'invite
comme je l'ai fait moi-même l'été
dernier la plupart des sénateurs qui
font beaucoup de stage à
aller dans à travailler dans ces grandes
surfaces en particulier et vous verrez
que la réalité et la liberté des
salariés est beaucoup moins grande que
ne le disent les
textes donc
contire
non non non c'est vous avez bien
voulu allez monsieur for vous laissez
pas
interrompriveive Président je ne vais
surtout pas me laisser interrompre par
la voix tonit truante de Monsieur bra
parce que sur ce plan là je peux encore
rivaliser par par les magasins de lourde
qui sont toujours ou tout le problème de
savoir en définitive quel modèle de
société nous voulons le lien social
doit-il seulement reposer sur la valeur
travail et sur l'activité
marchande et
enfin l'économie est-elle vraiment au
service de
l'homme cette loi si elle passe
démontrera totalement le
contraire
et il faut quand même
que on a quelques
points que nous pouvons partager sur le
plan sociétal nous devons pas remettre
en cause ce qui a
fait je crois l'harmonie de notre pays
et du vivre ensemble si notre pays a la
chance d'être un
modèle sur le plan mondial de démocratie
elle le doit essentiellement parce que
nous nos prédécesseurs n'aent pas
exclusivement créé une société sur des
ajustement technique comme on nous le
dit mais sur des valeurs
fondamentales parmi lesquelles qu'on le
veut ou non ce repos hebdomadaire est
absolument essentiel voilà pourquoi nous
considérons nous les sénateurs radicaux
et l'essentiel de notre groupe que il y
a des
à accepter cette loi d'abord on portera
atteinte au petit
commerce parce que ce sont c'est la
grande distribution qui tirera tous les
avantages et en
terme en
terme d'aménagement du territoire ça
sera relativement catastrophique on va
ensuite créer des disparités sur le
terrain qui seront génératrices
desésordres
et nous faire croire que c'est un simple
ajustement technique c'est une
duperie bien entendu si on demande à
n'importe quel consommateur qui a besoin
d'une baguette de pain à 2h de
l'après-midi est-ce que vous accepteriez
que votre boulangerie soit ouverte à 15h
il va répondre
oui mais à l'évidence ce n'est pas comme
cela qu'on créera une société
harmonieuse lesant ils sont pour la
grande distribution cette grande
distribution dont j'ai personnellement
stigmatisé certaines pratiques à savoir
que
depuis quelques années et cela réalisé
souvent en 10 ans ce sont les plus
grosses fortunes françaises qui sont
réalisées alors que dans la grande
industrie il fallait trois ou quatre
générations pour y arriver et bien on va
encore accentuer ce mouvement ça n'est
pas la conception que nous souhaitons de
l'économie au service de l'homme donc
c'est c'est un texte qui est nocif et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
majorité de mon groupe le rejettera avec
force la parole est à notre collègue
Monsieur Bruno
retaillot bonjour vous allez bien
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a des
débats qui dépassent les clivages
traditionnels parce qu'il relèvent non
pas d'une logique partisane mais parce
qu'ils engagent une conviction
personnelle c'est le cas de cette
proposition de loi relative mais nous
sommes bien d'accord c'est une habilité
sémantique au repos dominical et autant
dire franchement qu'il me semble que ce
texte va poser beaucoup plus de
difficultés qui ne va en résoudre pour
trois raisons d'abord il risque de créer
des différences de traitement que la
logique a du mal à justifier différence
entre les territoires territoire d'un
côté de l'Alsace Morel miselle de
l'autre territoire national différence
entre Lyon avec Paris Lille Marseille
différence entre les communes
touristique au sens strict auinus du
code touristique ou alors au sens du
code du travail différence et c'est
peut-être plus important aussi de
traitement pour les salariés puisqu'il y
a ceux qui travaillant le dimanche dans
les périmètres d'usage de consommation
exceptionnel seront payés le double a
ront un jour supplémentaire de repos
compensatoire il y aura ceux qui
travaillent depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
déjà dans les communes touristiques et
qui n'y auront pas droit ce que nous
propose ce texte en quelque sorte c'est
d'écorner ce vieux
principe qui veut qu'un travail égal
salaire égal et on entre dans une sorte
de relativisme
juridique dont je pense qu'il nous
amènera à créer énormément de complexité
plutôt que de
simplification deuxème difficulté je
crains aussi qu'en fait d'une simple
régularisation on enclenche un processus
de banalisation du travail du dimanche
le travail du dimanche deviendra au
moins potentiellement la règle dans les
communes touristiques que les deux
verrous traditionnels que sont d'abord
la limitation dans le temps la saison
que sont aussi la limitation sur le type
de du commerce vont sauter et même si
les puces n'engloopppent pour le moment
que trois grandes agglomérations c'est
pratiquement un/4 de la population
française qui va se retrouver dans la
zone de chalandise affecté par ses
rythmes de consommation et de production
nouveaux risque de contagion aussi
puisque bien sûr pour les salariés qui
vont travailler le dimanche il y aura
des services périphériques nécessaire à
l'accompagnement de leurs absences au
foyer de même que pour les magasins qui
seront ouverts toutes les entreprise
périphérique devront en même temps
suivre et les accompagner dans un
nouveau rythme et tout cela pour quel
bénéfice le bénéfice économique sans
doute sera-t-il incertain aucune étude
aujourd'hui n'est décisive pour montrer
que le travail du dimanche ne créerait
plus de croissance ou d'emploi en terme
d'aménagement du territoire il y a un
vrai risque d'effets collatéral
d'aspiration sur toute la grande zone de
chalantise autour de ces grands centres
au détriment bien sûr d'une
dévitalisation de l'arrière-pays mais
surtout mes chers collègues pour quel
bénéfice enfin en terme de cohésion
sociale la question fondamentale que
pose ce texte est la suivante quel prix
sommes-nous sommes-nous prêts à payer
collectivement pour régulariser des
situations
particulières je crois que nous sommes
un grand nombre ici à partager au-delà
nous sommes sensibilité politique la
même lecture de la crise économique
actuelle qui n'est autre que la
conséquence d'une logique financière
poussée à l'excès nous partageons aussi
sans doute cette idée comme un remède
peut-être que le marché propose
peut-être un modèle économique mais
certainement pas un modèle de société et
qu'il a besoin de limite en d'autres
termes ce n'est pas au marché de réguler
les activités humaines c'est à l'homme
de réguler les activités du marché avec
cette
avec cette proposition de loi nous
prenons le risque d'abîmer notre lien
social pour un profite aléatoire et au
bout du compte et au bout du
compte le choix que nous avons à faire
est bien celui de l'orientation d'un
modèle de société quelle cité
voulons-nous construire ensemble est-ce
un simple état marchand c'est-à-dire une
communauté de producteurs et de
consommateurs ou une véritable
communauté politique c'est c'est-à-dire
une communauté de citoyens rassemblés
dans un projet collectif merci de votre
attention la parole est à notre collègue
Monsieur Jean
Desessard allez à tout à
l'heure
ne vous cassez pas le col du fémur on
peut attendre une
minute monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le
Président il y a des
fois le Sénat son activité dans le bon
sens par exemple je me réjouis d'être
dans une commission qui a élu pour la
première fois une femme présidente de
commission c'est une évolution
positive mais monsieur le
Président il y a des fois où le Sénat
évolue dans le mauvais
sens et en particulier lquil traite la
majorité de ces lois en
urgence ce n'est pas bien monsieur le
Président et pourquoi vous traitez en
urgence monsieur le
ministre mais pour satisfaire la grande
distribution cela été
dit celle qui met en péril les commerces
de proximité que par ailleurs vous dites
défendre C qui étr les petits
producteur pays que vouses défendre et
là vous faites quoi au
un beau cadeau à la grande distribution
c'est contraire à tout ce que vous
pouvez dire par ailleurs alors ce texte
il est examiné non seulement en urgence
mais le fin du
fin sans aucun
amendement de la commission des affaires
sociales sans aucun
amendement à quoi servons-nous mes chers
collègues à quoi
servons-nous
non seulement moi parce qu'on pourrait
penser que quelqu'un de l'opposition bon
après tout il s sert pas il est dans
l'opposition son tour viendra ne vous en
faites pas mais
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui c'est vous
qui servez à rien aucun amendement alors
qu'on sait très bien que sur ce point-là
vous êtes partagé que vous avez des
différences qu'il y a des questions de
valeur fondamentales vous montrez à tout
le monde que le Sénat aujourd'hui ne
sert à rien voilà visiblement la
majorité obé aux ordres c'est-à-dire
obtenir un vote conforme à celui de
l'Assemblée nationale et cela le plus
rapidement possible sans discussion
voilà alors monsieur le
ministre vous utilisez la forme de
proposition de loi d'initiative
parlementaire au lieu de proposer un
projet de loi gouvernemental mais vous
avez beaucoup d'avantage
ça vous évitez la négociation avec les
partenaires
vous n'avez pas soumettre le texte au
Conseil d'État ni au Conseil économique
et social que de temps de gagner
allons-y alors
évidemment le choix d'examiner ce texte
en pleine période estivale est également
l'illustration des méthodes plus que
contestaes du gouvernement les Français
en vacances et découvriront la
banalisation du travail dominical à l'
rentrée évidemment là qu'il sera trop
tard alors je voudrais rappeler moi
aussi comme ma collègue de boucheedourô
que ce cette proposition de loi a été
proposée par le député des bouche du rô
Richard mailler et nous le savons tous
dans son département il y a le pôle
commercial de plan de campagne où les
commerces ouvrent le dimanche depuis
plusieurs années en toute
illégalité bien raisonnable d'examiner
une proposition de loi destinée à régler
non seulement une situation particulière
qui favorise des intérêts privés mais
qui couvre des infractions qui durent
depuis des
années alors monsieur le Président
àou que je félicite d'être président
d'un groupe centriste monsieur vous nous
avez dit on couvre on couvre les
infractions et après çaira mieux mais
qu'est-ce qu'il disent les patrons on
prend et on recommencera c'est c'est
comme ça qu'il disent je dis
bien la majorité argumente depuis
plusieurs semaines sur le fait que
l'ouverture dominicale des commerces
sera un jour de croissance en
plus et que les consommateurs ainsi que
les salariés attendent l'application de
cette proposition de loi pour gagner
plus et consommer plus est-il vraiment
indispensable de vous rappeler que nous
traversons aujourd'hui une crise
économique et où nos concitoyens
trouveront l'argent à dépenser le
dimanche alors qu'ils n'ont déjà pas
assez d'argent le lundi le mardi le
mercredi le jeudi le vendredi et le
samedi alors toutes les études le
démontrent l'ouverture dominicale des
commerce ne favorisera pas la
consommation car il n'existe pas
aujourd'hui de réserve de consommation
il n'existe pas badeline et on attend le
dimanche pour aller dépenser au mieux il
s'agira de rapport d'achat ça a été dit
par ma collègue
Texier effectué le dimanche au lieu du
samedi l'expérience des pratiques
européennes montre également que le
chiffre d'affaires des commerce ouvert
le dimanche n'évolue pas à la hausse de
plus dans la mesure où le travail
dominical ne génère pas une augmentation
de la croissance économique cette
disposition n'aura aucune incidence sur
la création d'emploi alors ça a été dit
d'un point de vue sociétal nous ne
pouvons que constater que des points
négatifs à la banéalisation du travail
dominical diminution des voilà et on
interrompt cette séance mouvementée sur
le repos dominical elle reprendra juste
après le journal de 18h la vie
sociale bonsoir à tous et on commence
avec les titres de ce journal fin de
session parlementaire agité à
l'Assemblée nationale le vote de la loi
adopie 2 a été reporté à la rentrée les
deux groupes majoritaires et opposition
se rejettent la responsabilité au Sénat
le travail le dimanche donne lieu à de
vif débat extrait dans ce journal et
puis Paul emploi débordé comment le
service public va faire face à une
rentrée qui s'annonce difficile et bien
grâce à des opérateurs
privés les éléphants du PS volle au
secours de Martin auri malmené par les
jeunes loups du parti la première
secrétaire peut à présent comp sur les
poids lourds du
PS et enfin dans le volet économique une
mauvaise nouvelle avec une baisse
inédite des crédits à la consommation au
premier semestre le montant des nouveaux
crédits à la consommation enregistre un
net recul de 15 %. les invité du 18h
c'est l'une de ses premières
interventions télévisées depuis qu' les
ministre Michel Mercier sera avec nous
il est en charge de l'espace rural et de
l'aménagement du territoire et puis le
débat du 18h flambé des impôts locaux
suppression de la taxe professionnels
les collectivités locales sont-elles
condamnées à payer les peau cassées de
la crise on va en parler tout à l'heure
avec Jean artui président de la
commission des finances du Sénat et le
sénateur socialiste de la Côte d'Or
François repsamen c'est juste après le
journal et puis on va commencer avec au
Sénat le travail le dimanche et le
feuilleton qui n'est pas encore fini à
la Haute Assemblée l'opposition monte
aussi au créneau contre ce texte voté
avec beaucoup de difficultés par les
députés la semaine dernière on va
écouter un bref extrait des change
plutôt vif de la discussion c'était cet
après-midi cette proposition de loi est
le fruit
d'un travail de plusieurs années et
d'une longue réflexion
elle a suscité parce que certains nous
disent on a commencé hier c'est faux et
a suscité de vif écoutez écoutez on vous
a écouté vous en avez raconté des choses
ah moi je peux faire ça aussi si vous
voulez hein si vous voulez que je le FE
je vous le fais hein voilà je fais ça et
tout le monde va être content voilà et
là vous faites quoi aujourd'hui un beau
cadeau à la grande distribution c'est
contraire à tout ce que vous pouvez dire
par ailleurs alors ce texte il est
examiné non seulement en urgence mais le
fin du
fin sans aucun
amendement de la commission des affaires
sociales sans aucun
amendement à quoi servons-nous mes chers
collègues à qu
servons-nous voilà et je vous le disais
une séance donc plutôt agitée et sur le
fond les sénateurs de l'opposition
dénoncent les inégalités induites par ce
texte deux points inquiètent
particulièrement certains sénateurs le
nombre de communes à vocation touristiqu
concerné et les contreparties salarial
le point avec Marie
bremo à chacun son dimanche la
proposition de loi sur le travail
dominical aujourd'hui au Sénat n'accorde
pas le même traitement à tous les
salariés concernés on va se retrouver
dans un système à deux vitesses avec
certaines enseignes certains secteurs
qui devront offrir des compensations à à
leurs salariés et d'autres pas du tout
voilà une nouvelle inégalité la
rémunération sera fonction des zones
définies dans le texte de loi dans les
puces périmètres d'usage de consommation
exceptionnelle les grandes agglomération
en fait les partenaires sociaux ont
l'obligation de négocier en cas
d'absence d'accord les salariés
bénéficieront d'un paiement double alors
que dans les zones dit touristiques et
termales seule l'obligation de négocier
sera exigée mais pour le rapporteur de
la proposition ces distinctions sont
tout à fait justifiées dans les stations
touristiques ça n'est pas du tout le
même rythme de travail que dans les
puces dans les puces c'est toute l'année
tous les jours enfin sauf bien sûr les
jours s fermé parce que ou par roulement
alors que dans les zones touristiques
quelque fois ça s'adresse que deux ou
trois mois de l'année donc ça ne peut
pas être exactement la même chose un
point de vue fermement contesté par
l'opposition il y a tellement
d'inégalités enfin il y a des inégalités
tellement flagrantes dans ce texte que
de mon point de vue le Conseil
Constitution
va dire ça va bien ça passe pas les
parlementaires de gauche ont en effet
annoncé leur intention de saisir les
juges du palaisroyal sur ce texte
controversé et puis à l'Assemblée
nationale le vote de la loi ADOPI 2 a
été reporté à la rentrée la semaine ne
se fera donc pas à examiner le millier
d'amendements déposés par les députés de
l'opposition et chacun a sa propre
version sur ce rapport selon Jean-Marc
hot président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée la majorité n'est pas unie
sur le projet de loi agacé le chef des
députés UMP Jean-François Copé insiste
lui de nouveau sur le manque de
responsabilité de ses collègues de
l'opposition puis les éléphants du PS
volent au secours de Martin auri alors
que Manuel Vass estime dans une tribune
au Financial Times que le PS est en
danger de mort les poids lourd du parti
apporte leur soutien la première
secrétaire Bertrand de laanoué Laurent
Fabius mais aussi ségolen Royal font
blog derrière Martine auri Fabrice cy
c'est Jean-Marc qui le premier ce matin
est venu apporter son soutien à Martin
le président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée a dénoncé une attitude
morbide de certains et balayé l'idée
d'un changement de nom du parti comme le
souhaite manuel Vals on peut pas se
réclamer de Jean jores en permanence y
compris le président de la République
tout découvrir que le mot socialiste est
ringard il est plus actuel que jamais
simplement il faut lui donner du contenu
il faut lui donner des des réponses aux
questions de notre temps même
l'indiscipliné Jack Lang est venu au
secours de la première secrétaire pour
lui le PS est u un arbre sec mais il
faut arrêter les petites phrases et
faire des propositions il faut qu'on
sorte de la NAS il faut qu'on sorte de
cet enlisement et le seul moyen de d'en
sortir c'est qu'un petit comité qui aura
la confiance de tous puisse faire des
propositions de doctrine et d'action qui
permettrait de de sortir je le répète de
cette de cette Moise la plus attendue
était sans aucun doute Segolen royale et
ce matin elle a elle aussi appelé à un
retour au calme j'apporte mon soutien à
tous les social e dont Martin au BRI qui
travaill qui font des efforts qui
essayent de se relever et quand on est
très très mal vous savez c'est vrai de
tout toute organisme quand on est très
très mal si on travaille ça va forcément
aller mieux mais ça nous demande
énormément d'énergie d'intelligence de
réflexion en commun de modestie de
changement de méthode de changement de
pratique la présidente de poitoucharante
a donner rendez-vous aux journalistes à
la rentrée rendez-vous est pris fin août
aux universités du parti à La Rochelle
dans son fief cesgolen royale pourrait
là encore monopoliser
l'attentionés débordé PUL emploi fait
appel à des sous-traitants privés dans
la perspective d'une rentrée qui
s'annonce difficile le service public de
l'emploi peaufine son plan d'urgence
pour faire face à l'afflux de chômeurs
et bien Paul emploi intensifie sa
collaboration avec les opérateurs privés
les grands cabinets de recrutement mais
aussi les poids lourds de l'intérim sont
sur le rant Carole pugol et anneelouise
Dean Paul emploi et agenintérim main
dans la main pour sauver l'emploi c'est
en substance le message que Bery voulait
faire passer ce matin une collaboration
entre public et privé dont le but avouer
est la relance mais aussi la mise en
concurrence de deux façons de travailler
ça fait des années que nous avons décidé
de faire appel les opérateurs extérieurs
c'était le cas d'e temps ind il y avait
46000 demandeurs d'emploi qui étaient
pris en charge par les opérateurs
aujourd'hui ça sera 120 à 160000 par an
là on a une crise d'une très grande
ampleur si on compte uniquement sur
propres forces et qu'on dit p l' emploi
tout seul c'est la réponse à tout on
s'illusionne il y a aucune piste qui est
solution miracle mais aucune piste n'est
à négliger je le rappelle si on peut
s'appuyer sur les agences d'intérim je
vais pas négliger ça à court terme il
s'agit de traiter plus de dossier en
moins de temps ainsi que d'aider plus
précisément à la recherche d'emploi que
l'on soit chômeur de longue durée ou pas
et c'est ce que fait cette agence depuis
longtemps pour eux comme pour les 15
autres agences qui ont répondu à l'appel
d'offre l'enjeu est de taille travailler
avec l'État et chacun y va de son
innovation nous avons pu nous donc
mettre en place des des dispositifs
innovants par exemple euh ce que nous ne
faisions pas auparavant et qui
aujourd'hui est vraiment nécessaire
favoriser la recherche d'emploi sur
Internet de façon autonome pour un
demand d'empemploi ou bien aider un
demand d'emploi à se préparer en 3
minutes à un entretien de recrutement
puisqu'on sait que les trois premières
minutes d'un entretien de recrutement
sont sont fondamentales l'agence ou les
agences choisies seront régulièrement
contrôlées reste une grande inconnue le
budget seule certitude début septembre
tout devra être
opérationnel allez on va parler à
présent d'économie qui dérange l'idée
peut paraître surprenante en temps de
crise et de prise de conscience face au
danger du réchauffement climatique mais
EDF demande aujourd'hui une compensation
au manque à gagner que représenteraiit
selon elle des réductions de
consommation d'énergie proposé par l'un
de ses fournisseurs les explication de
Thomas
Raget
bonjour l'objet qui pose problème au
four isseur d'électricité le voici un
petit boîtier fixé près du compteur
après paramétrage et en votre absence il
va couper les appareils qui ne servent à
rien comme les radiateurs électriques ou
les ballons d'eau chaude a priori je
devrais économiser entre 10 et 15 % sur
ma consommation annuelle sur sur
l'ensemble des factures quoi une
solution prometteuse dont dispose
quelques milliers de particuliers à
titre expérimental eux ne payent rien
celui qui rémunère l'opérateur Voltalis
c'est RTE le réseau de transport de
l'électricité notre revenu vient du côté
de RTE le gestionnaire du réseau de
transport d'électricité qui est chargé
d'assurer l'équilibre sur son réseau par
la loi et pour assurer l'équilibre ça
veut dire en permanence régler la
demande et l'offre la production et la
consommation donc quand la consommation
va dépasser la production d'habitude RTE
appelait une production supplémentaire
production chère et plante en général
nous nous proposons de rétablir
l'équilibre quand un déséquilibre se
creuse en réduisant la consommation si
RTE et Voltalis semblaient s'être
entendu sur ce mode de financement
celui-ci pose pourtant problème à la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie ce
mode de rémunération n'est pas conforme
à la loi aujourd'hui et pose un problème
sur l'équilibre même du système entre
les fournisseurs le réseau de transport
d'électricité et un opérateur comme
Voltalis qui vient d'avoir une idée
intéressante mais qui veut se rémunérer
d'une manière qui pose problème si la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
dément l'idée évoquée récemment de
Voltalis elle propose à l'opérateur de
réfléchir à un partenariat annuel avec
le réseau de transport d'électricité du
côté du ministère de l'Énergie on
annonce la création d'un groupe de
travail chargé de réfléchir à cette
question et puis sur le problème
sensible des colonisation à Jérusalem
est le kedoré convoque l'ambassadeur
israélien à Paris après Washington Paris
fait donc pression l'objectif est de
réclamer à Israël l'arrêt de la
colonisation un appel relayé aujourd'hui
par la présidence suédoise de l'Union
européenne il faut s'abstenir de toute
action provocatrice à Jérusalem est
selon la présidence de l'Union et dans
le même temps Nicolas Sarkozi recevait
le président égyptien aussi Mubarak le
chef de l'État français a de nouveau
plaidé pour la tenue d'une conférence
internationale afin de relancer le
processus de paix entre Israël et les
Palestiniens il faut arrêter de laisser
du temps au temps a-t-il précisé puis on
finit par cette nouvelle c'est la mort
de Maurice Gréau préfet de police de
Paris en mai 1968 il est mort à l'âge de
95 ans les historiens s'accordent pour
dire que c'est grâce à sa modération
notamment qu'il n'y a pas eu de victimes
lors des émeutes de Mai 68 à Paris la
suite de notre journal dans quel état
sont nos collectivités locales
vont-elles devoir augmenter les impôts
locaux pour s'en sortir c'est le départ
du 18h mais tout de suite notre invité
le ministre Michel
Mercier bonsoir Michel merci bonsoir
alors on le rappelle vous êtes ministre
de l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'espace rural et d'ailleurs c'est quoi
l'espace rural ah bien d'abord c'est une
excellente question parce que il va
falloir j'ai à définir aussi l'espace
rural c'est pas simplement un espace
c'est des lieux de vie de vie pour des
hommes des femmes des enfants qui sont
sur un territoire qui est relativement
vaste dans notre pays et c'est aussi un
territoire qui accueille de plus en plus
de population puisque on a il y a plus
de baisse de la population au milieu
rural il y a une augmentation de la
population donc il y a de nouveaux
ruraux qui viennent vivre dans le monde
rural et avec qui coexiste avec les
agriculteurs oui il y a un vrai désir de
campagne les Français mais est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'ils veulent y travailler il
s'y installent ça fait du bien d'être à
la campagne est-ce qu'ils y travail bah
pour certains ils veulent y travailler
ce qui pose la question de l'accès aux
technologie notamment euh au haut débit
et c'est un un des grands dossiers
peut-être le grand dossier euh de mon
ministère pour l'instant c'est faire en
sorte que tous les territoires a accès
au au débit paré hier sur ce même
plateau avec Nathalie queiscorisé qui
veut réduire justement cette fracture
numérique tout à fait et moi je je
souhaite je pense que le grand emprun va
pouvoir nous aider parce que c'est
vraiment une dépense d'avenir et vous
êtes écouté sur ce sur ce projet on a
présenté nos demandes je crois que
chacun s'accorde à à dire que c'est un
projet intéressant je dire que si le
premier ministre et le président de la
République ont voulu ce ministère
nouveau comme on dité nouveau avec
l'espace l'esace et l'aménagement du
territoire c'est bien parce que
peut-être encore en période de crise
plus que dans les autres périodes l'État
ne peut pas laisser les choses aller
tout seule il faut pouvoir les organiser
et les organiser bah c'est rôle d'un
ministre de l'aménagement du territoire
et de l'espace RAL vous l'avez dit c'est
un nouvel intitulé vous avez déjà pris
vos marques vous Michel Mercier je suis
en train de prendre Mac moi mon but
c'est à la fin du mois de juillet départ
en vacances être capable être en état de
de faire des propositions claires au
Premier ministre et au président de la
République après à eu de choisir et et
d'arbitrer auelà de tout ça donc je
rencontre mes collègues ministres avec
lesquels je dois travailler les élus
locaux les préfets tous les spécialistes
du territoire tous ceux qui ont quelque
chose à dire et et je veux à partir de
là bâtir une doctrine nouvelle de
l'aménagement du territoire de tous les
territoires et je veux pas au poser le
rural et l'urbain je crois que c'est
l'alliance des territoires avec un état
stratège qui organise cette alliance et
qui sera la base de des propositions que
je présenterai au président de la
République au Premier ministre beaucoup
d'élus mais vous rencontrez aussi des
jeunes agriculteurs c'était il y a hier
dans le beauelet votre territoire leurs
inquiétudes sont fortes aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent de vous je
crois d'abord qu'ils
attendent de l'attention ça c'est
premier point de pas être abandonner
laisser comme ça ils attendent que de
l'état des préfets des sous-préfets des
élus des ministre une une écoute et ça
c'est le premier point après ils
attendent que on leur permette de vivre
leur vie de ruraux tel qu'on veut la
vivre aujourd'hui
danse dans un monde 80 ou 90 % des gens
sont urbains c'est les standards Dee
urbaines qui sont présents partout on
veut même si vous êtes dans un village
tout petit 50 habitants vous avez besoin
d'avoir accès à Internet vous avez
besoin d'avoir accès à la télévision
numérique terrestre vous avez besoin
d'avoir accès à la téléphonie mobile
vous avez besoin d'un système de
permanence des soins vous avez besoin
d'un système
pourp comment vous répondz à T ces Bess
aujourd'hui vous avez l'enveloppe
nécessaire vous avez le budget nécessire
pour
l'instant on en est moi je vais utiliser
d'abord les budgets des autres je sais
que par exemple je viens de voter ave
j'aiaccord sénateur
la loi qu'a présenté Madame Bachelot sur
la santé les
territoires je sais que là il y a des
crédits par exemple pour créer des
maisons médicales moi j'ai bien
l'intention de proposer des maisons
médicales pour le monde rural des
systèmes de garde particuliers pour le
monde rural sénateur Juliard vient de
faire un rapport voilà je vais m'en
inspirer oui je je prétends pas inventer
mais je me sens assez bien coucou pour
prendre un peu tout ce qui est bon ce
qui est proposé justement justement en
vous écoutant on se rend compte que
c'est un ministère qui touche un petit
peu à tout et qui prend des morceaux à
tous les ministères ça doit pas être
facile à gérer quand on sait que chaque
ministre veut garder le maximum de ses
prérogatives comment vous gérez ça avec
les autres avec vos collèguesi je pour
ma part je je reste fidèle à la
définition même du mot ministre ça veut
dire serviteur donc ça veut dire avoir
une politique et essayer de la servir le
mieux possible après les histoires
d'ego j'ai passé l'âge ça mais
complètement égal
donc particulier tout à fait que je sois
assis devant derrière à
côté c'est pas mon affaire ça n'a pour
moi pas d'importance ce qui a une
importance c'est de laisser une trace de
faire des choses les construire pas
simplement de de faire des grands
systèmes avec rien au bout mais faire
des petites choses tous les jours qui
montreront qu'on avance alors laissz une
trace probablement aussi pour
l'aménagement du territoire c'est
l'intitulé de votre ministère aussi
est-ce que vous êtes associé aujourd'hui
à la réforme des collectivités locales
tout à fait tout à fait vous travaillez
en tendème avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur bien sûr le responsable
principal de de cette réforme c'est
normal c'est tradition dans notre pays
que le ministre de l'Intérieur et le
ministre des collectivité locale mais le
président de la République a souhaité
que je sois associé brissortefeu l'a
souhaité il le fait très bien donc on
travaille ensemble avec Monsieur marnex
brisstefeu et les tendê se passe bien ça
se passe très bien parce qu'on se
connaît pu parce que on n' pas si vous
voulez de de il y a pas de raison que ça
se passe mal parce que on n pas
d'ambition contrarié ni les un ni les
autres et puis comme il va probablement
y avoir un bon mois et demi de séance au
Sénat notamment de nuit et je pense
qu'on sera tous contents qu'on soit
trois se partager le boulot plutôt qu'un
seul bon ça pose pas de
problème on est d'accord sur les
objectifs ce qui est quand même
l'essentiel Michel merci après tant
d'années ici au Sénat aujourd'hui vous
êtes ministre qu'est-ce qu'elle vous
apporte la fonction ministérielle bah
elle m'apporte une autre vision
c'estàdire que moi j'étais heureux dans
ce que je faisais au Sénat président
d'un groupe certes petit mais qui fait
la majorité c'est d'abord une
responsabilité et une une ouverture
aussi sur ce que pensent les autres
aujourd'hui ministre c'est avoir une
politique à mettre en œuvre c'est donc
des choses beaucoup plus matériell
concrèt B c'est aussi l'achèvement d'une
carrière d'élu ce qui est des fois
frustrant quand on est parlementaire et
et moi j'avais un exécutif local donc je
pourais faire des choses ça c'est
important quand on est parlementaire et
si on n pas l'occasion de faire des
choses on les fait en théorie ministre
on doit les faire in concréto très
concrètement d'ailleurs vous y êtes
préparé depuis longemps il paraît que
déjà dans la cour d'école communal de
tis vos copains vous prédisez déjà un
avenir ministériel ils ont pu d déjà ça
blag de copain voilà apparemment qui ont
abouti des blagues assz sérieuses voilà
merci beaucoup merci mich merci
la suite du 18h avec ce débat dans quel
état sont nos collectivités locales
vont-elles devoir augmenter les impôts
locaux pour s'en sortir leur difficultés
s'accumulent suppression de la taxe
professionnelle crise économique
financement bancaire en baisse et
désengagement de l'État les
collectivités locales souffre oui mais
pas en silence les éliux locaux inquiets
montent au créneau et l'une des pierres
d'achopppement concerne la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle une recette
importante pour les collectivités alors
comment compenser cette perte
Jean-Baptiste
daulas la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle c'est 22 milliards
d'euros en moins pour les collectivités
locales pour limiter le manque à gagner
le gouvernement envisage une double
compensation une taxe sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises et aussi une
dotation que l'État verserait chaque
année aux collectivités donc nous aurons
une somme budgétaire affectée il n'y
aura plus d'autonomie fiscale il en aura
une autonomie financière dans un cadre
législatif avec les nouvelles
compétences qui sera totalement figé
c'est un retour en arrière de près de 30
ans par rapport aux premières loi
decentralisation après la réforme les
entreprises devraient économiser environ
5 milliards d'euros par an et les sommes
qu'elles ne paieront plus aux finances
publiques le gouvernement va devoir les
trouver ailleurs des taxes
environnementales comme la taxe carbone
sont à l'étude avec le risque
d'augmenter la pression fiscale cette
fois-ci sur les ménages il est sûr
qu'avec ce qu'on appelle les impôts
environnementaux il va y avoir une
nouvelle répartition et pas forcément
sur les entreprise il va y avoir un
partage entreprise et forcément ménage
ce qui ne plaît pas à tout le monde mais
quelque part on devra procéder de de
cette manière le gouvernement doit
rendre ses arbitrages avant la fin du
mois de juillet la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle devrait entrer en
vigueur progressivement dès 2010 comment
se portent nos collectivités local
quelles seront quel est l'impact sur les
contribuables nous allons en parler avec
Jean ui président de la commission des
finances du Sénat et François repsamen
sénateur socialiste de la Côte d'Or et
d'abord une première question est-ce que
nos collectivités locales vont si mal
qu'on le dit jeanartu quel est V
diagnostic je crois que globalement euh
elles font face à leurs obligations mais
elles sont confrontées à un effet de
ciseau d'une part elle doiv assumer des
charges dont elle ne maîtrise pas
l'ampleur parce que bien souvent elle se
trouve dans l'obligation d'engager des
dépenses parce que le législateur l'a
prévu et peut-être sommes-nous
quelquefois insuffisamment conscient des
contraintes qui vont peser sur le
terrain de la soutenabilité financière
de ce que préconise la loi pour les
collectivités c'est vrai au plan social
c'est vrai dans de multiples domaines et
par ailleurs leurs ressources se
trouvent limitées certaines d'entre
elles sont en baisse je pense par
exemple au département ils perçoivent la
taxe les droits de mutation à titre
obligatoire sur les transactions
immobilières il vous a pas échappé que
depuis quelques mois le nombre de
transactions a beaucoup baissé et que la
valeur des actifs sur lesquels sont
calculés ces droits ces valeursl sont
aussi en baisse et ce sont des moinsvalu
quelqu fois de 30 ou 40 % mais est-ce
qu'elles font assez d'effort pour faire
des économies pour le secrétaire général
de l'élyisée Claude guant non parce
qu'en matière par exemple de réduction
du nombre des fonctionnaires si l'état
fait son devoir apparemment les
collectivités locales ne le font pas FR
et c'est des collectivités de gauche
majoritaement bien sûr l'État est mal
venu de donner des leçons à des
collectivités locales qui se comportent
et Jean arartus vient de le dire de de
manière exemplaire dans une situation de
crise elles investisent
elles investissent beaucoup elles
contractualisent leurs investissements
avec l'État dans le cadre du plan de
relance elles sont aujourd'hui le
dernier lien de proximité avec nos
concitoyens c'est vers les communes
notamment mais les collectivités locales
que se tourn nos concitoyens quand tout
va mal et et donc vouloir aujourd'hui
affaiblir les collectivités locales
c'est porter un mauvais coup à
l'équilibre de notre pays et à nos
concitoyens qui sont confrontés à cette
crise que le secrétaire général de
l'Élysée disent ça euh c'est son droit
le plus strict bien évidemment mais vous
savez les collectivités locales c'est
pas Jean artuis qui me contreddira n'ont
pas le droit aujourd'hui d'avoir des
déficits de fonctionnement quand elles
empreunent c'est pour investir et
uniquement pour investir et donc
effectivement il faut qu'elle fasse euh
qu'elle soit solide face à la crise elle
gère très bien elle gère bien mieux que
l'État elle gère bien mieux que l'État
et donc son son respons
sont des propos qui sont mal venus
permettez-moi de le dire en revanche je
pense qu'il faut quand même se préparer
à la réforme parce que depuis quelques
décennies on assiste à un empilement de
collectivité territoriale nous avons à
peu près 37000 communes et comme
nombreux d'entre elles sont trop petites
pour conduire des projets de
développement elles se regroupe en
communauté de commune ou en communauté
d'agglomération ou en communautés
urbaines mais comme ça ne suffit pas on
regroupe des communautés de communes en
pays à l'échelon infradépartemental et
lorsque vous interrogez euh le
citoyen compqué fait quoi entre la
commune la communauté de commune le pays
le département et RG rent sondage
peut-être vous l'avez voulu près de 50 %
des Français se disent mal informés sur
le fonctionnement de leur collectivité
mais même les élus quelquefis s'y
perdent donc je pense qu'il est très
important euh nous élus territoriaux
puisque nous avons des mandats locaux
d'accepter d'entrer dans une démarche de
de réforme euh il est temps de décider
comme l'a dit Édouard Baladur alors il
est temps de décider aussi et sur l'un
des sujets d'inquiétude des élus c'est
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle il faut pour le
gouvernement aujourd'hui trouver une
solution une recette de substitution et
c'est pas du tout gagné puisque quelques
pistes ont été évoqués mais c'est
reporté à la rentrée qu'est-ce que vous
proposez est-ce que vous avez des pistes
en tête François repsamen alors d'abord
je je voudrais dire que les
collectivités locales aujourd'hui sont
dans une dans une situation où on fait
appel à à elle le gouvernement pour
faire face pour maintenir
l'investissement en période de crise et
ça je crois que c'est à rappeler
deuxièmement je suis absolument en
opposition avec l'idée de déstabiliser
dans la période où nous vivons les
collectivités locales c'est dans la
période de crise que nous connaissons
les collectivités locales qui ont au
contraire besoin en ce moment il
n'empêche qu'il faut faire certain
nombre de réformme mais qui ont besoin
en ce moment de visibilité comme les
entreprises peuvent en avoir besoin et
on nous annonce et on nous annonce en ce
moment justement la suppression d'une
des recettes les plus importantes des
colleccr la taxe professionnelle procure
pour vous des ressources pour 79
millions d'euros au Grand Dijon 31
millions d'euros au Conseil Général de
la Côte d'Or et 15 millions d'euros
conseil régional de Bourgogne la
communauté d'agglomération c'est voilà
c'est 80 millions d'euros demain avec la
réforme qui nous est proposée à peu près
dont on voit se dessigner les contours
ça sera 37 millions de recettes de taxes
professionn et le reste forcément
espéronsle au moins une compensation de
l'État mais sinon qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on augmente les impôts locaux mais
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mais pourquoi
voulez-vous aujourd'hui suffisait de
minorer je le pense progressivement de
15 % de 30 % la part que payent les
entreprises industrielles parce que
c'est celles-là qui sont aujourd'hui
pénalisé par la taxe professionnelle
mais les autres ne le sont absolument
pas elle continue de se développer j'ai
reçu hier une entreprise Jean artuis qui
qui veut s'implanter à Dijon 600 emplois
à la clé c'est une belle belle promesse
et bien nous avons une taxe
professionnelle ils m'ont pas posé la
question de la taxe professionnelle qu'
av ça ne les gêne pas à part les
entreprises industrielles lourdes ça
j'en
convient l'automobile mais ce n'est pas
leur problème d'ailleurs vous verrez que
les endroits les plus dynamiques sont
souvent ceux où il y a le plus de taxes
professionnelles parce que c'est là où
il y a le plus de services qui sont
rendus aux entreprise c'est
contradictoire ça jeu c'est la réalité
sur le terrain je crois quand même que
en cette période qu'on appelle encore
crise j'espère que c'est une crise
c'est-à-dire que c'est un mauvais moment
à passer ce ce que je crains c'est que
la France a perdu une partie de son
potentiel de croissance pourquoi parce
que nous vivons en économie global et
que les acteurs économiques les
entreprises vont rechercher les lieux
géographiques où les conditions sont les
plus avantageuses pour produire or il se
trouve que nous en France nous
maintenons une partie de notre fiscal h
fiscalité locale fiscalité pour assurer
le financement de la protection sociale
de la branche santé de la branche
famille avec des des prélèvements qui
sont des coûts de production d'accord
c'est vrai pour la taxe professionnelle
donc on pe alors parquoi les remplacer
d'abord se mettre dans l'esprit il est
de bon ton c'est politiquement
extrêmement correct de dire voilà les
entreprises payent et les ménages payent
mais sont toujours les ménages qui
payent parce que il y a-t-il seul impôt
payé par une entreprise de Dijon je suis
sûr que dans le prix de la moutarde il y
a le montant de la taxe professionnelle
par conséquent les consommateurs de
moutarde payent la taxe professionnelle
mais à maintenir cette taxe
professionnelle dans un nombre assez
considérable de production on prend le
risque d'activer des délocalisations
d'emploi et de perdre un potentiel de
croissance donc le vrai débat c'est de
savoir si nous sommes prêts à réviser
nos prélèvements obligatoire pour
retrouver les meilleurs atouts de
compétitivité et de poss possible
création d'emploi c'est c'est ça le vrai
combat qu'il faut mener alors si on
exonère de taxes professionnelles alors
il faut que le geste aille jusqu'à son
terme et donc il faut expliquer aux
Français que ce sera forcément un impôt
de consommation qui peut-être soit une
taxe carbone auront à supporter
évidemment bah oui ou alors un
supplément d'impôt sur le revenu mais si
vous si vous mettez un impôt de
consommation vous sujettiz à l'impôt ce
qui vient de l'étranger alors que sans
cela vous ne taxez que ce qui est
produit chez vous François rsaman une
réponse j'ai évoqué oui mais je je
comprends je connais les arguments on en
a déjà débattu on parlera encore on en
parlera encore bien sûr parce que la
difficulté va être pour la prochaine loi
de finance d'avoir un dispositif qui
soit juste et qui permette au moins une
juste compensation pour les
collectivités qui investissent mais
aujourd'hui ce que je constate euh
jeanus c'est les entreprises
industrielles qui sont incontestablement
pénalisées à
travers mais c'est comme ça que je vois
également que euh puisque moi je parle
de ce que je connais c'est-à-dire mon
environnement économique sur sur Dijon
euh 80 % aujourd'hui des implantations
son les entreprises étrangères qui
viennent de s'installer à Dijon à Dijon
80 % des entreprises qui s'installent
sont les entreprises étrangères et sont
les entreprises suédoises sont les
entreprises allemandes sont des
entreprises suisses alors qu'on a'ille
pas me faire croire ou me dire que c'est
la raison principale de la
délocalisation les délocalisations se
sont produites sur les coups de main-
d'œuvre vous le savez essentiellement
maintenant elles peuvent se produire
elles se sont produites sur la part
salaire ça a été supprimé maintenant
elles peuvent se produire sur les
investissements lourds j'étais moi pour
une solution qui prenait en compte les
établissements industriels mais exonéré
de de taxes de de taxes professionnelles
exonéré de taxes professionnelles les
sociétés d'autoroute exonéré euh
aujourd'hui EDF exonérer ça ça n'a aucun
sens à part faire un cadeau et
transférer encore plus sur les impôts
ménages Françis r on va continuer parler
on va parler du PS une dernière question
jeartu sur les déficit oui vous nallz
pas y échapper
non une dernière question sur sur les
déficits sur l'endettement de l'État
est-ce que l'État on sait que le
Parlement aujourd'hui suit de très près
notamment le Sénat la situation
d'endettement de l'État mais est-ce que
l'État a les moyens de contourner
aujourd'hui le circuit parlementaire
est-ce que est-ce qu'on dit que l'État
est en train d'emprunter discrètement à
très court terme est-ce que c'est le cas
non non non bien sûr l'autorisation
l'autorisation parlementaire porte sur
l'endettement à plus d'un an alors à
court terme et à court terme il peut il
peut il peut faire du crédit revolving
ce qu'il est en train de faire comme un
comme un consommateur qui aurait des
cartes de crédit et qui fera du crédit
revolving par on dit pour le
consommateur c'est dangereux est-ce que
pour l'État c'est dangereux oui c'est
dangereux en tout cas c'est une bonne
politique aujourd'hui puisque le taux
d'intérêt à courterme est inférieur à 1
% mais c'est parfaitement un deor et
c'est l'insoutenable légèreté la det det
donc contrairement au collectivité
territoriale l'État n'a pas l'obligation
d'amortir ses emprunts alors c'est c'est
c'est très commode pour
s'alerter donc je pense que au plan
pédagogique j'ai d'ailleurs fait des
propositions au Sénat la semaine passée
je souhaite que désormais on puisse
inscrire une fraction d'amortissement de
la dette très bien pour que les Français
prennent la mesure de l'urgence et de la
nécessité qui n'a pas envie de parler de
PS voulez répondre à jeanui oui mais je
suis pas forcément desaccord sur
l'analyse qui est faite par je de la
dette où nous avons où nous avons
peut-être un desésaccord c'est que ce
que je vois c'est que l'État aujourd'hui
diminue sans cesse ses recettes fiscales
je veux pas revenir au bouclier fiscal
mais à travers des niches à travers des
exonération de TVA l'état perd
énormément de recett fiscal on a estimé
à peu près 90 milliards d'euros de perte
de recette fiscale que c'est dépenses
même s'il y a des efforts qui sont faits
continuent de croître et que l'État est
dispendieux à avec moins de recettes et
plus de dépenses donc je propose de
rétablir des dépenses c'est peut-être là
des des recettes pour le l'état bien sûr
d'établir à nouveau des recettes pour
l'État c'est-à-dire de de non pas dans
une mesure simpliste de faire payer ceux
qui ont beaucoup mais qui ait de la
justice fiscale et la justice fiscale
c'est
forcémentendement de l'État pour la
situation du Parti socialiste Jea c'est
pour pas parler du parti socialist de
questions après toutes ces critiques sur
l'état du parti sur Martin auri vous qui
n'avez pas été tendre avec elle mais
quel est aujourd'hui votre diagnostic de
la situation écoutez le Parti socialiste
est confronté à une grave crise le nier
serait se voiler la face et faire preuve
de beaucoup de légèreté on va dire et
donc il est confronté à une crise de
leadership il est confronté à une crise
de stratégie et il est confronté à un
développement incommensurable de des
égau des uns et des autres donc touché
le fond et donc il ne peut ça ne peut
qu'aller mieux comme Royal il faudra je
pense il faudra bien sûr il faut d'abord
se remettre au travail
mais il faut résoudre les problèmes de
désignation de nos candidats à travers
des primaires il faudra y venir il faut
élargir la base électorale parce que
l'élection de Martin auri a été frappé
du péché originel donc vous la souz
aujourd'hui je soutiens ceux qui
travaillent je soutiens les socialistes
qui trava trava est-ce que vous la soutz
elle travaille ben il faut qu'elle
rassemble encore plus et surtout qu'elle
arrête de se comporter comme elle le
fait de temps en temps en amateur bon et
alors dernierot qu'est-ce que vous
attendez là qu'est-ce qui va se passer à
la sortie de l'été qu'est-ce que vous
attendez comme démarche nouvelle de sa
part si elle devait prendre une action
une mesure symbolique aujourd'hui et
bien de faire adopter d'abord de
remettre de la démocratie dans le Parti
socialiste de faire participer nos
adhérents nos militants qui sont encore
très nombreux à tous les processus qu'il
ait à nouveau un lieu d'élaboration
collective il n'y a plus de lieu
d'élaboration collective c'est ça le
principal reproche qu'on peut faire
Martine Aubri ne peut pas fonctionner en
vase clos entouré de quelques
conseillers c'est pas comme ça que le
Parti socialiste doit fonctionner et
remettre de la démocratie s arrêter de
de rappeler à l'ordre oui enfin ça on
voit bien que c'est une épée de bois
qu'elle avait Martin Aubri donc ça ne
sert à rien ça remet en valeur ceux qui
se comportent pas toujours très bien
d'ailleurs en la matière et je pense
qu'il est temps que les vacances
arrivent pour repartir d'un bon pied
alors Jean artuiier à présent président
d'alliance centriste quel est votre
regard un mot sur ce qui se passe sur ce
parti socialiste quel est votre regard à
vous moi je je me garder
de toute ingérance et on peut pas dire
que les les partis politiques en général
soient dans une forme olympiqueord nous
avons une société qui souffre des des
concitoyens qui sont dans le doute et
qui
s'interrogent se demandant si le
politique a bien compris l'ampleur des
difficultés qu'ils ont à résoudre
quotidiennement donc je pense que nous
avons tous le devoir de rénover auss le
débat à l'intérieur des partis
politiques il est quand même
symptomatique la crise mais je pense que
c'est c'est plus qu'une crise c'est
probablement la fin d'une époque et nous
devons nous préparer à à jeter un autre
regard sur l'art de vivre ensemble nous
avons des débats qui bien souvent pour
des raisons de conservatisme de
dogmatisme nous empêche de bouger nous
empêche d'avancer parce que chacun est
sur des positions tactiques parce que
c'est la tyrannie du court terme ne va
pas au-delà de la prochaine élection
ceci met le pays en péril en matière
fiscale en matière de gouvernance
publique nous avons des réformes
fondamentales à accomplir ne serait-ce
que dans le fonctionnement même du
Parlement très bien ben Jean ui il faut
donc bouger il faut avancer c'était le
mot d'or du président d'alliance
centriste c'est la fin de ce journal
merci beaucoup messieurs on reprend tout
de suite la séance sur le repos
dominical très très bonne soirée publque
Sénat la parole est à Monsieur Hervé
Moré merci merci
à
merci bonjour vous allez bien
oui beaucoup
d'agglomération monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente Madame la
rapporteur nous sommes maintenant amenés
à
examiner le texte tendant à réaffirmer
le principe du repos dominical et à
adapter les dérogations à ce principe
dans les communes et zones touristiques
et thermales ainsi que dans certaines
grandes agglomérations pour les salariés
volontaires voilà un titre bien long
pour une proposition de loi qui a mis
bien longtemps à arriver jusqu'à nous et
et qui finalement nous propose une
réforme à minima tant l'idée d'étendre
le champ du travail dominical a suscité
polémique et réaction hostile dans la
classe politique conduisant l'auteur de
la proposition de loi à revoir pas moins
de trois fois sa copie j'ai moi-même
fait l'expérience de ces réactions
puisque certains s'en souviennent sans
doute j'avais déposé n'est-ce pas Madame
la rapporteur du projet de loi tourisme
j'avais déposé des amendements dans le
cadre du projet Doig tourisme tendant
à modifier le régime d'ouverture
d'ouverture dominicale des magasin en
zone touristique tandis que mon collègue
ifpzo di Borgo déposait lui un
amendement concernant les zone de plus
d'un million d'habitants et ces
amendements avaient entraîné des
réactions très violentes et je me
souviens très bien que sur la dizaine de
parlementaires qui étaient intervenus au
moment de de mon amendement un seul
était venu soutenir ma démarche c'est
mon collègue philippe Dominati qui est
là et j'en profite pour le remercier
alors j'espère j'espère que 3 mois plus
tard les dispositions qui étaient
inacceptables dans un amendement vont
devenir tout à fait acceptable dans
cette proposition de loi je considère et
je continue à penser que cet amendement
avait toute sa place dans une loi
tourisme qui aujourd'hui est adopté donc
le dispositif serait mis en place et que
par ailleurs à l'Assemblée nationale on
a mis en place une mesure qui avait
certainement encore moins sa place qui
était la baisse de la TVA dans la
restauration je voudrais également vous
faire part de mon étonnement pour ne pas
dire de ma
stupéfaction que notre commission des
Affaires économique n'est pas jugé
nécessaire de se saisir d'un projet de
loi tel que celui-là contrairement à la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'Assemblée nationale lorsque j'ai posé
la question en commission on m'a répondu
que ce projet n'avait pas de dimension
économique alors si ce projet n'a pas de
dimension économique j'avoue que je ne
vois pas bien ce que nous faisons ici et
pour ma part je considère qu'il a une
dimension économique c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi je le soutiens et je citerai je
citerai pour rassurer pour rassurer tout
le monde sur mes conviction profonde je
citerai le président de la République
qui le 23 octobre dernier déclaré la
possibilité de travailler sur la base du
volontariat le dimanche c'est un jour de
croissance et de travail en plus c'est
une occasion en plus de vendre ses
produits sur la base du volontariat et
pour les salariés qui veulent travailler
le dimanche une occasion d'être payé
davantage cela sera bon pour le pouvoir
d'achat et donc soyez rassurés je
j'adhère pleinement au propos du
président de la République simplement je
ne comprends pas que notre commission
des affaires économiques n'it pas vu la
dimension économique de ce texte dernier
regret parce que je ne veux pas
m'exprimer que pour formuler des regrets
dernier regret celui que le gouvernement
nous demande encore un vote
conforme la semaine dernière on nous
demandait un vote conforme sur la loi de
programmation militaire la semaine
d'avant c'était un vote conforme sur la
loi tourisme on finit par se demander à
quoi sert le Sénat vous me direz on a de
la chance on nous propose une
disposition qui n'est pas encore mise en
application ce qui est somme tout assez
rare
alors je crois que c'est quand même tout
à fait regrettable d'autant plus que
chacun reconnaît que le Sénat a toujours
un apport tout à fait positif dans la
rédaction des textes pour peu évidemment
qu'on lui laisse s'exprimer et qu'on lui
laisse la possibilité d'amender les
textes qui lui sont
proposés alors venons-en au fond sur le
fond moi je crois qu'il faut démystifier
imp de cette proposition de loi ça n'est
certainement pas le grand soir du
travail dominical c'est un texte qui ne
remet pas en cause le repos dominical le
repos dominical ça a été rappelé il a
été créé par la loi de 1906 il est
réaffirmé par ce texte le repos
dominical il connaît de nombreuses
dérogations chacun sait qu'il y en a
plus de 180 chacun sait que des
gouvernements de droite et de gauche y
compris madame Aubri lorsqu'elle est
ministre du Travail ont mis en place des
dérogations chacun sait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui à peu près un tiers des
Français qui travaille déjà de manière
occasionnelle ou régulière le dimanche
donc je crois encore une fois qu'il faut
arrêter de jouer à se faire peur parce
que cette proposition de loi on l'a dit
qu'est-ce qu'elle propose elle propose
que la fermeture des magasins de détail
le dimanche a lieu à 13h au lieu de 12h
je crois que ça ne pose aucun problème
bon elle propose elle propose de
modifier le régime applicable dans les
zones touristiques et de créer de
nouvelles dérogations temporaires dans
les périmètres d'usage de consommation
exceptionnelle alors concernant les
zones touristiques allez je vais encore
citer le président de la République on
ne peut quand même pas être le pays au
monde qui reçoit le plus de touristes et
être le seul pays au monde où la
quasittalité de nos magasins dans la
totalité de nos régions sont fermé le
dimanche j'avais eu l'occasion j'avais
eu l'occasion dans le débat
j'avais eu l'occasion dans le débat
tourisme de souligner le caractère
absurde du régime et je ne reviendrai
pas sur les exemples fameux des lunettes
de soleil qu'on peut vendre le dimanche
mais pas des lunettes de vue des
vêtements qu'on peut vendre s'ils sont
assimilé à de la Création artistique
mais pas à du prête àortter honnêtement
je ne crois pas ma chère collègue qu'il
n'y ait que Madame Obama qui a envie
d'aller dans les magasins quand elle
fait du tourisme le dimanche il y a
quantité
vient à Paris pourire onitès bien que
les grands magasins Figur parmi les
monuments les plus visités et bien plus
visités qu'un certain nombre de
monuments histori donc il faut pas
voiler la face et je crois que
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
notamment à Paris aura un impact
extrêmement positif en terme d'emploi et
en terme de commerce extérieur quand au
périmètre d'usage de consommation
exceptionnelle il concerne les grandes
agglomérations Paris Marseille Lille ex
et des zones où il s'agit de sécuriser
des des situations qui existe parfois
depuis de très nombreuses années et puis
et puis il s'agit aussi en zone
frontalière d'éviter que les
consommateurs français partent faire
leur courses dans des pays qui ont des
législations moins conservatrices que
les nôtres je suis donc de ceux qui
pensent non' déplaisent à la commission
à laquelle j'appartiens que cette
proposition de loi un impact économique
et qui plus a un impact économique
positif en terme d'emploi et en terme de
pouvoir d'achat je crois également
qu'effectuer certains achats le dimanche
n'est pas contrairement à ce qu'on nous
raconte antinomique avec la vie de
famille je suis désolé il y a des achats
il y a des achats importants pour
l'ensemble de la famille que la famille
souhaite pouvoir effectuer ensemble je
crois également je crois également que
dans la vie moderne telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et surtout en milieu urbain
quand vous avez le père et la mère qui
travaill et qui souvent le weekend le
samedi pardon sont occupés par les
activités périscolaires des enfants
activités culturelles et sportives
souvent ils sont bien contents de
trouver un temps pour faire des achats
le dimanche alors naturellement
naturellement l'extension du régime
dérogatoire doit s'accompagner de
garanties pour le salarié parce que
c'est vrai que le dimanche n'est pas un
jour comme les autres et qu'il faut des
garanties ces garanties quelles
sont-elles c'est premièrement le le
volontariat et deuxièmement des
contreparties sur le volontariat je
crois que le texte le texte réaffirme
très clairement le principe du
volontariat qui a été réaffirmé à
l'Assemblée nationale à la suite d'un
amendement du groupe Nouveau Centre
puisque ce volontariat devra être
formulé par écrit je rappelle que ce
volontariat est révocable et je rappelle
aussi que le refus de travailler le
dimanche ne peut pas conduire un
demandeur d'emploi à être radié des
listes des demandeurs d'emploi et oui
mais c'est vrai chers collègues quant
aux
compensations le texte prévoit le
doublement du salaire et un repos
équivalent dans les périmètres d'usage
de consommation exceptionnelle et dans
le cas des autorisations données par le
maire là aussi l'Assemblée nationale sur
proposition du groupe centriste du
groupe Nouveau Centre a obtenu
l'obligation d'une négociation
collective et je crois que c'est une une
excellente chose il y a donc des
garanties en terme de compensation et en
terme de valeur de volontariat on ne
peut que regretter que ces mesures ne
soient pas généralisées c'est le seul
regret que j'ai il y a effectivement un
risque d'augmenter les inégalités entre
les travailleurs le dimanche puisque
certains vont bénéficier d'un doublement
du salaire alors que d'autres seront
bien loin d'avoir une telle majoration
de salaire et c'est pourquoi je me suis
per bien que on été incité à ne pas le
faire a déposé un amendement très
modeste mais qui propose à l'article 4
que le comité d'évaluation qui est créée
par cet article 4 et qui doit élaborer
un rapport et bien que ce rapport
examine les différentes compensations
selon les différents salariés
travaillants le dimanche et propose des
mesures pour favoriser leur
harmonisation alors pour
conclure pour conclure je dirais que ce
texte n'est certainement pas parfait et
qu' n'a certainement la pas la
prétention de la perfection mais que ce
n'est pas le texte
caricatural que nos amis de l'opposition
veulent présenter c'est un texte je le
rappelle qui ne supprime pas le repos
dominical mais qui le confirme c'est un
texte qui modifie simplement le régime
dérogatoire sur la base du volontariat
il va dans le bon sens il permet
d'adapter la législation aux réalités
aux évolutions de la société et à la
nécessité de conforter l'attractivité
touristique et économique de notre pays
c'est vrai que l'attractivité économique
du pays parfois ça échappe à certains
sur ces bancs mais pour nous c'est
quelque chose d'important et c'est pour
cela c'est pour cela que comme l' dit le
président Nicolas Abou un nombre
significatif de sénateurs du groupe
Union centriste votera ce texte je vous
remercie Paro est collèue monsieur alain
GOURNAC
allez monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur chère
Isabelle Debray mes chers
collègues cette proposition de loi est
le fruit
d'un travail de plusieurs années une
longue réflexion elle a suscité parce
que certains nous disent on a commencé
hier c'est faux elle a suscité de vif
écoutez écoutez on vous a écouté vous en
avez raconté des choses ah moi je peux
faire ça aussi si vous voulez si vous
voulez je je vous le fais voilà c'est ça
et tout le monde va content voil moi
j'ai un respect pour le Sénat et je ne
le ferai pas
elle a suscité de viv débat à
l'Assemblée nationale également au sein
de notre commission sur un sujet aussi
passionnel que celui du travail de
dimanche je pense qu'il faut éviter la
caricature on a entendu tout à l'heure
la
caritature hein à entendre certains le
texte porte atteinte au droits des
salariés et banalise le travail le
dimanche au contraire l'article 2
l'article 2 vous l'avez lu réaffirme le
principe du repos dominical dans
l'intérêt des
salariés par cette proposition de loi il
ne s'agit pas d'étendre le travail du
dimanche à l'ensemble du territoire il
ne s'agit pas de révolutionner le droit
existant il s'agit simplement d'apporter
des réponses ciblées à des questions
spécifique ainsi le texte vise TR
cas ouverture du commerce ce dimanche
dans les communes et zones touristiques
et oui ça faut peut-être ouvrir les les
boutiques quand il y a les
touriste l'ouverture dans des périmètres
d'usage de consommation exceptionnelle
les puces le droit pour les commerces
alimentaires ça c'est très là c'est très
grave que je vais vous dire le droit
pour les commerces alimentaires de
fermer à 13h au lieu de midi le dimanche
ça c'est une honte vraiment une heure de
plus dans
on constate que le droit ne répond pas
aux réalités du commerce il n'est pas
nécessaire de parler longuement de la
prolongation de l'ouverture des
commerces alimentaires jusqu'à 13h cela
ne pose pas de difficulté car cette
pratique est progressivement entrer dans
les fêtes ça existe mes chers collègues
dans le cas des communes touristiquesoui
ça existe sorte le dimanche are m 1h
dans le cas dans le cas des communes
touristiques actuellement un commerce ne
peut ouvrir que s'il met à disposition
du public écoutez bien des biens et
services destinés à faciliter son
accueil ou ses activités de loisirs
d'ordre sportif récréatif ou culturel
est-il normal et j'ai mon collègue l'a
dit tout à l'heure et le cas est souvent
cité qu'un magasin situé dans une
commune touristique puisse ouvrir le
dimanche s'il vend des lunettes de
soleil alors que la Boutique d' qui V
des lounettes de V ne peut pas qu'un
vendeur de chaussures de sport je répète
qu' vendeur de chaussures de sport mes
chers collègues puisse ouvrir mais pas
un vendeur de chaussures de
ville de nombreux oui ça arrive madame
il y a beaucoup d'Italiens alors vous
connaissez très bien le commerce
beaucoup d'Italiens qui vient acheter
des lunettes de vue en France je vous
l'annonce de nombreux contentieux
italien de nombreux contentieux sont
dans ces incohérences il est évident que
la réglementation en vigueur est
imparfaite et d'application complexe la
situation paraît injuste aux commerçants
et invraisemblable aux touristes
étrangers et français je le rappelle la
France est la première destination
touristique mondiale et pourtant et
pourtant nous ne sommes que 3è en
recette issue du tourisme il y a
beaucoup de touristes qui passe le
weekend à Paris pourquoi ne pas leur
donner la possibilité de consommer le
dimanche avec des produits
français la question la question oui
c'est mieux qu'il parte ou oui c'est
mieux qu'il parte en Angleterre vous
avez raison c'est vrai oui ils vont
aller acheter en Angleterre c'est c'est
une bonne chose la question non mais
c'est c'est mieux à Londres il achètent
à londr tout est ouvert la question de
l'ouverture dominicale des commerces s
également essentiel dans lesones
frontalière il suffit de passer la
frontière pour faire ses courses le
dimanche alors que nos commerces sont
obligés de rester fermé contre toute
logique non c'est inacceptable
l'ouverture dominicale dans les
périmèdes d'usage de consommation
exceptionnelle appel les puces ça rien à
voir avec les Puces de Paris dans les
très grandes agglomérations les Français
souhaitent faire leurs achats le weekend
c'est comme ça surtout quand il concerne
certains
comme par exemple l'équipement de la
maison la décoration parce qu'on y va
avec sa femme on y va avec ses enfants
et on fait un choix et on fait un choix
ensemble dans une France de plus en plus
urbaine l'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche apparaît comme une évidence les
Français passant beaucoup de temps dans
les transports il est évident que ce
n'est pas le soir en rentrant du travail
qu'ils peuvent faire leur achat mais
bien le weekend pourvu que les magasins
soi ouverts pour le moment mais pour un
moment constatons regardons ils sont
obligés de faire leur cours ce samedi
lorsque tous les magasins sont
bondés ou bien ils font leur cours sur
Internet là il est vrai le danger est là
pour les commerce de proximité le
Conseil économique et social a mis
l'accent à plusieurs reprises sur les
nouveaux rythmes de vie et les nouveaux
comportements de consommation il a
précisé que de nombreux salariés sont
prêts à travailler le dimanche que de
nombreux salariés sont prêts à
travailler le dimanche c'est eu qui
disent oui oui je dis de fois parce que
c'est Conseil économique c'est
d'ailleurs déjà le cas pour de nombreux
Français les chiffres de Lig C montr que
3,4 million de Français travaill
habituellement dimanche et 4 million
Casement 4 oui ça doit faire ça faire le
total qui a été donné dans les hôpitaux
trava dans les hôpitaux les
commissariats trava aussi les services
de secours mais mes chers collègues il
travaillent aussi les restaurants
figurez-vous qu'il travaillent aussi
dans les restaurants non mais c'est
incroyable ou les transports et bien
arrêtons arrêtons la caricature
regardons la réalité de ce qui se passe
dans notre pays acceptons cette
réalité et également dans les magasins
qui sont attaqués en justice aujourd'hui
si on ne légaliserait pas l'ouverture de
dimanche pour ces commerces ouvert de
longue date il se verrait contraint de
supprimer des
emplois pour parler du travail dominical
il faut déjà connaître la réalité
nombreux très nombreux sont les salariés
intéressés pour travailler le dimanche
parce que cela leur permet d'être mieux
payé la oui c'est vrai mais c'est comme
ça bon vous pouvez faire oh c'est comme
ça la proposition de loi prévoit pour
les salariés travaillant dans les puces
périmètre d'usage de consommation
exceptionnelle que leurs conditions
salariales dépendront des accords
collectifs à défaut d'accord ils
percevont obligatoirement
obligatoirement le double de leur
salaire au minimum dans le cas des
communes et zones touristiques la
proposition de loi ne prévoit pas de
garantie particulière mais un amendement
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale impose
impose que des négociations soient
engagées sur ce sujet dans toute les
branches du commerce ou des
contreparties ne sont pas prévu au
moment où notre pays traverse une des
crises les plus graves de son histoire
quelqu'un l'a oublié tout à l'heure il y
a un orateur qui nous a expliqué qu'il
avait du chômage il sait pas que la la
crise est là je lui rappelle je lui
rappelle je lui rappelle je lui rappelle
je lui rappelle je lui
rappelle le travail de dimanche fait
partie des solutions pour créer de
l'emploi on peut d'un revers de main le
souhait de nombreux salariés confrontés
à d'importantes difficultés pourquoi
pourquoi leur interdire de travailler à
partir du moment où ils sont volontaires
pourquoi les
interdire chacun doit être libre de
travailler le dimanche et chacun doit
pouvoir choisir de ne pas le faire si
cela ne correspond pas à son mode de vie
l'opposition
Gén il j é question c'est fa ça
faetteation français je suis autant
attaché que vous chers collègues au
repos de
médicalant notre groupe notre groupe est
attaché à l'équili familial à la notion
d'un dimanche partagé en famille et
d'ailles ce dimanche peut partagé en
famille dans l'achat d'un meuble pour la
maison avant une séance de cinéma mais
il y aura du monde dans le cinéma il
travaille aussi c'est un scandale il
voilà qui travaille de dimanche dans les
cinémas ah dis donc franchement
franchement le dimanche est un jour
différent des autres pour des raisons à
la fois culturel spirituel familial et
social nous ne souhaitons pas que le
visage du dimanche
change mais nous refusons oui mais
écoutez tout vous faites mais attentez
tout mais nous refusons que le respect
des traditions par le lit face le lit de
l'archaïsme qu'une vision conservatrice
conservatrice écoutez le mot du repos
dominical nous empêche d'adapter notre
droit à la réalité du commerce dans les
deux cas dont j'ai parlé les zones
touristiques et les très grandes
agglomérations le législateur doit faire
preuve de pragmatisme en reconnaissant
qu'il peut exister des dérogations au
principe du repos dominical ce n'est pas
scandaleux il en existe déjà 180
introduites par des gouvernements de
tout horizon politique je tiens à
insister sur les nombreuses garanties
entourant le texte tout d'abord en ce
qui concerne les communes et zones
touristique la décision d'application se
fera au niveau local à l'initiative des
maires faites confiance un peu au maire
et avec l'accord du préfet donc au plus
près du terrain lors des débats à la
Assemblée nationale certains ont tenté
de nous faire croire qu'une multitude de
communes seraiit concerné il faisait
l'amalgame entre le classement des
communes touristiques selon le code du
travail et le classement des communes
touristiques selon le code du tourisme
deux procédures distinctes la procédure
relevant du Code du travail a permis de
classer environ 500 communes
touristique contre plus de 3500 selon le
terme du Code du tourisme mais j été
question il n'a jamais été question
d'appliquer le code du tourisme puisque
cela ne semblait pas suffisamment clair
les députés ont qualifié de communes
d'intérêt touristique les communes
relevant du Code du travail afin de les
différencier toute confusion toute
confusion est
désormais évité en ce qui concerne les
nouveaux périmètres d'usage de
consommation exceptionnelle plus le
texte cré également plusieurs garanties
profit des salariés ces conditions
concernent d'abord la procédure à suivre
initiative du conseil municipal
consultation du conseil de communauté
fixation du périmètre de la zone par le
préfet il est important de le de confier
cette responsabilité aux élus locaux moi
je fais confiance aux élus locaux qui
ont le plus de légitimité pour évaluer
les besoins et les attentes de la
population ces conditions concernent
également la nature des garanties
accordées l'accord collectif prévoira
des contreparties pour les salariés op
pour compensateur et majoration
salariale à à défaut d'accord collectif
la décision unilatérale de l'employeur
sera soumise à un référendum et le
salarié bénéficiera au minimum au
minimum d'un doublement de salaire et
d'un repos
compensateur l'Assemblée nationale a
apporté encore d'autres garanties une
entreprise ne pourra refuser d'embaucher
une personne qui refuse de travailler le
dimanche l'évolution la situation du
salarié sera prise en compte notamment
par le 3 pour ceux qui le souhaiteraient
une priorité vers les emplois ne ncitant
pas un travail de dimanche le droit du
salarié de revenir sur son choix est
reconnu tout le mécanisme institué par
la proposition de loi repose sur le
volontariat le texte issu des débats de
l'Assemblée nationale a été amélioré et
nous sommes présentés toutes les
garanties possibles concernant les
salariés aussi aussi le groupe UMP
suivra-t-il l'avis de notre rapporteur
qui n'a pas souhaité le modifier bien
évidemment notre groupe votera cette
proposition de loi qui conserve qui
concerne l'équilibre qui conserve pardon
l'équilibre entre le respect du repos
dominical et la reconnaissance
d'exception très encadrée je vous
remercie mais j'ai pas fait ça ça très
bien monsieur le Président si vous
voulez je peux vous faire ça va très
bien ça va très bien nous sommes pas
obligés allez la parole est à notre
collègue Monsieur Jacques
mzard bonjour
monsieurard monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
oui radicaux ont été et continuent à
être les apôtres du repos
dominical ajourné en décembre dernier
faute de majorité dans la
majorité la discussion sur le travail
dominical revient en force devant le
Parlement dans une version soi-disant
plus
édilcorée permettez-nous d'en douter le
travail dominical ce n'est pas le remède
à la crise cela se saurait
nous avons
l'impression que ce texte est un cheval
de TR introduit en plein jour dans le
droit du
travail ce n'est certes pas le grand
soir mais c'est une
expérimentation dont nous connaissons la
suite surtout quand on se sert du
tourisme comme
paravant mon collègue François Fortassin
a tout à l'heure parfaitement démontré
les dangers de ce texte
une proposition de loi dont le titre est
la réaffirmation du principe du repos
dominical pour en fait saperer ce
principe nous
inquiète tout d'abord d'une manière
générale au moment où le code du travail
n'est plus un code mais une accumulation
de texte disparat un maquis juridique
est-il opportun de rajouter de nouvelles
dérogations génératri de conflit
d'interprétation est-il opportun de
diversifier encore
davantage l'application de la loi entre
les territoires c'est le meilleur moyen
de rendre la loi illisible et difficile
d'application lois différentes selon les
territoires inégalité accru entre les
salariés est-ceel un
progrès bien sûr plusieurs millions de
Français comme cela vient d'être rappelé
travaille régulièrement ou
épisodiquement le dimanche la santé en
est un exemple illustratif et
l'évolution de la société mes chers
collègues justifie des changements
auxquels nous ne sommes nullement
opposés à la condition que l'évolution
législative soit transparente et diminue
les inégalités sociales et territoriales
au lieu de les
aggraver contrairement aux effets
d'annonce la proposition de loi sur le
travail dominical est loin de garantir
que les salariés qui travaillent le
dimanche seront tous volontaires et
payer double nous assisterons à beaucoup
de nominations de volontaires désignés
vous aviez pourtant affirmé monsieur le
ministre que le volontariat serait la
règle et le doublement des salaires
assuré pour tous les salariés qui
accepteront de rendre ce service
particulier dans les zones et communes
d'intérêt touristique thermal l'exposé
des motifs de la proposition de loi le
rappelle tout emploi est susceptible
d'impliquer pour un salarié un travail
le dimanche puisque cela découle de
facteurs structurels cela signifie
clairement que dans ces communes il n'y
aura ni volontariat ni majoration de
salaire ni repos compensateur
c'est-à-dire aucun des avantages
promis le
rapporteur le rapporteur a regretté à
juste titre
que le ministre du Travail ne soit pas
en mesure de fournir la liste des
communes concernées dont les préfets
devraient pourtant disposer ce n'est pas
rassurant pas davantage que de prendre
pour seul exemple le magasin Vuiton
avenu et Champs-Élysées certes
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un un
amendement imposant que des négociations
soit engagé dans toutes les branches du
commerce ou des contreparties au travail
dominical ne sont pas déjà prévu mais il
n'y a là aucune obligation de résultat
cette proposition de loi met donc en
place un système à deux vitesses selon
le lieu de travail provoquant ainsi une
rupture d'égalité entre l'ensemble des
salariés du dimanche ce que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter par ailleurs dans
les périmètres urbains de consommation
exceptionnel les puces où le volontariat
et la règle il est illusoire mes chers
collègues de croire cette période
économiquement difficile où le chômage
ne cesse d'augmenter les salariés auront
réellement la possibilité de refuser de
travailler le dimanche ce que vous
présentez comme un choix deviendra dans
la pratique une obligation pour les
salariés ne nous voilons pas la face les
employeurs disposent encore plus en
période de crise de facilité pour
imposer leurs conditions de travail
croire que seuls les salariés
volontaires travailleront le dimanche
procèdent d'une méconnaissance totale du
fonctionnement même des entreprises en
effet comment croire qu'un employeur ne
tiendra pas compte du refus d'un salarié
à travailler le dimanche et que cela
n'aura aucune incidence sur les
augmentations les primes les promotion
comment être sûr que le refus de
travailler le dimanche ne sera pas un
motif de refus d'embauche et que se
passera-t-il lorsque le nombre des
volontaires ne sera pas
suffisant la puce question la puce a
toujours eu le don mes chers collègues
de se reproduire facilement et de
transmettre quelques germes
pathogène le texte qui nous est soumis
est donc un texte
d'opportunité élargissant une brèche au
contour mal défin dans notre droit du
travail c'est pourquoi la majorité de
notre groupe ne la votera
pas
la parole est à Madame Giselle
prince alle
doucement
bonjourz
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues il n'y a pas si
longtemps en janvier 2007 plus
exactement je me souviens être intervenu
dans la discussion générale d'un projet
de loi de modernisation du dialogue
social il visait à accorder aux
partenaires sociaux à temps de
négociation avant tout examen
parlementaire d'un texte portant sur le
travail l'emploi et la formation
professionnelle ce texte voulait être
celui du rachat de la réconciliation du
gouvernement de de l'époque avec des
partenaires sociaux après les avoir
ignoré systématiquement durant la
précédente
législature malheureusement les
mauvaises habitudes reviennent vite
alors que le travail dominical
constituait une des promesses de
campagne du candidat Nicolas Sarkozi
alors que les déclarations tonit
truantes sur la liberté de consommer et
de et le droit de travailler plus se
multipliait il y a quelques mois on
pouvait s'attendre à d'prc tion avec des
partenaires sociaux majoritairement
hostille au travail dominical mais il
n'en a rien
d'été en effet le gouvernement n'a
finalement déposé aucun projet de loi
sur le travail dominical aussi c'est une
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui une proposition de loi à
minima serais-je tenté de dire qui
viendrait réaffirmer le principe du
repos dominical et ne serait là que pour
g quelques situations urgentes mais
personne n'est dupe l'intention de
libéraliser le travail du dimanche est
omniprésent dans ce texte qui élargit
notamment les possibilités de dérogation
aux zones et aux communes d'intérêt
touristique ou thermal au moins 6000
communes sont concernées et d'ailleurs
pourquoi vouloir réaffirmer le principe
du repos dominical alors qu'il figure
sur blanc à l'article L 3132 TR du Code
du travail il y a là de quoi semer le
doute comme l'a rappelé mon collègue
monsieur Fortassin historiquement le
repos du dimanche vient de la Bible mais
la révolution l'a abolie en
1789 il fut réintroduit lors de la
restauration puis annulé une fois le 12
juillet 19
1880 le jour chumé était alors décidé
par le patron sa réintroduction date de
19 106 elle fut votée sous le
gouvernement de Ferdinand sarien afin
d'apaiser de vive tension sociale après
la tragédie de la mine de Courrière mais
aussi religieuse moins d'un an après la
séparation de l'Église et de l'État la
loi starien est toujours d'actualité
même si de nombreuses érogations sont
venues la compléter au fil du temps ne
nous y trompons pas c'est d'un vrai
choix de société dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui un choix entre le dimanche
est le jour du patron défendre le repos
dominical ce n'est pas défendre un
simple jour de repos c'est défendre une
conception de la vie de la vie de
famille tout d'abord celle-ci doit
pouvoir se retrouver ailleurs qu'au
supermarché au moins une fois par
semaine autour d'un repas d'une activité
commune sportive culturelle une fête
seul le dimanche le permet c'est aussi
l'occasion de se promener de rendre
visite aux parents aux grands-parents
pour les enfants le rendez-vous du
dimanche en famille est un facteur de
stabilité et d'équilibre et il n'y a pas
si longtemps monsieur le ministre vous
déclariez que l'école du samedi matin
n'est pas favorable à la vie familiale
pensez-vous que le travail du dimanche
le soit
davantage d'ailleurs les Français ne s
tront pas d'après un récent sondage près
de 55 % de nos concitoyens sont hosil au
travail dominical et pour 80 % d'entre
eux le dimanche doit rester à jour
différent des autres un jour où l'on ne
travaille pas ensuite défendre le repos
dominical c'est aussi défendre la vie
associative c'est souvent le dimanche
qu'on se réunit pour une fête de quaré
une carermesse d'école une fête
patronale autant de moments où se tisse
le lien social le sport se pratique
également le dimanche que ce soit pour
le jogging du matin ou pour des
compétitions sportives chaque semaine ce
sont des milliers de bénévoles qui
s'activent aux quatre coin du pays pour
faire vivre leur passion et pourtant le
bénévolat est en crise croyez-vous
monsieur le ministre que celle de ceux
qui travailleront le dimanche vont
continuer à s'engager enfin n'oublions
pas la vie religieuse nombre de nos
concitoyens ont le droit de pratiquer
leur culte le dimanche c'est tout à fait
respectable or s'ils travaillent ils ne
pourront pas le faire et pour les non
pratiquants les office les mariages les
baptêmes les communions et confirmations
sont des moments importants des
centaines de milliers de salariés seront
privé en totalité ou en partie c'est
regrettable je souhaite à présent me
livrer à une petite chasse à la
désinformation sur ce texte on nous dit
que les sal pardon que les salariés
seront payés double le dimanche mais ce
n'est pas exact d'ailleurs à ce propos
le président de la commission des
affaires sociales de la assemblé parler
de grosses bourdes bien bien évidemment
tous les salariés qui travailleront le
dimanche ne seront pas payés doubles
puisque ceux des zones touristiques et
thermales sont d'A et déjà exclus du
dispositif pour ceux des zones
commerciales autour de Paris lî et
Marseille les fameuses puces s'il en a
déjà un s'il y a déjà un accord
collectif de branche c'est l'accord tel
quel qui s'applique et si cet accord ne
prévoit pas de double rémunération rien
ne changera pour les
salariés donc le doublement
n'interviendra éventuellement que pour
les métiers où la convention collective
ne prévoit pas ce cas c'est-à-dire une
toute petite minorité car beaucoup
d'accords de branche ne prévoient pas de
doublement de salaire et s'il y a fort à
parier que la prime éventuelle liée au
travail du dimanche dans les puces
tendra très naturellement à disparaître
en proportion de la banalisation du
travail du
dimanche c'est ce qui s'est passé en
Angleterre c'est ce qui s'est passé en
Irlande et c'est déjà ce qui se passe en
France où l'amendement kou ka amendement
de Bré dispose déjà que le travail du
dimanche des salariés du secteur du
meuble ne comporte aucune compensation
salariale on nous dit que les salariés
auront le choix de ne pas travailler le
dimanche mais c'est mconnaître le lien
de subordination entre l'employeur et le
salarié les rapports de force et les
qui peuvent régner dans la grande
distribution d'ailleurs l'actualité
récente nous donne raison trois salariés
ont été licencier pour avoir refusé de
travailler le dimanche dans le magasin
aide d'yonax dans l' ces salariés
avaient pourtant été informé que le
travail dominical se ferait sur la base
du
volontariat cet exemple est
particulièrement
significatif de ce que veut dire
volontariat l'une des trois salariés
après 7 années de bon et Loyau service a
préféré renoncer à une Prim de 5 € et
réserver son dimanche à sa famille
puisque c'est le seul jour où elle peut
voir son fils en interneant à la semaine
résultat insubordination et non respect
des horaires planifié selon la direction
et licenciement dans la foule je n'ose
imaginer le nombre de cas similaires qui
passent inaperçu car non motivé de la
sorte je vais arrêter là cette chasse à
la désinformation sur ce texte il y
aurait encore beaucoup à dire par
exemple nous ne pensons pas qu'il soit
créateur d'emploi contrairement à ce qui
est affirmé je souhaite évoquer encore
un point important celui des femmes en
effet elles sont 63 % à travailler dans
le commerce donc les plus nombreuses et
les plus touchées par les conséquences
du travail dominical sur la vie
familiale on le sait la situation des
femmes est difficile sur le marché du
travail où leur taux de chômage est
supérieur à celui des hommes et les
écarts de salairire restent
significatifs
elles sont aussi plus nombreus que les
hommes à occuper des contrats à durée
déterminée et à temps partiel c'est
particulièrement vrai dans la grande
distribution où s'ajoutent des horaires
discontinus et des amplitudes
d'ouverture de plus en plus grandes
ainsi quand un magasin ferme à 20h ou à
22h il faut encore faire la caisse
prendre les transports en commun rentrer
à la maison et se lever tôt préparer les
enfants avant de les conduire à l'école
le dimanche arrive un point nommé de la
vie de ces femmes souvent mère
célibataire combien même elle serait
payé double si par chance le raccord
collectif de branche le prévoit si l'on
retire une garde d'enfant le dimanche
très onéreuse quand elle existe au final
il ne restera pas grand-chose en
définitif ce texte porte un coup sévère
à l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes qui non contente d'être soumise à
la précarité devront en plus renoncer à
leur équilibre
familial pour conclure nous percevons un
profond malaise autour de ce texte
rédigé sans concertation ni avec les
partenaires sociaux ni avec les
associations d'élus locaux sous prétexte
de régler quelques situations urgentes
on ouvre la porte sur un changement de
société majeure un changement aux
conséquences désastreuses sur la vie
familiale de nos citoyen beaucoup l'ont
compris mais ça de la majorité j'en veux
pour preuve ce vote sans enthousiasme à
l'Assemblée nationale pour toutes ces
raisons nous sommes absolument contre le
vote de
cette de ce
texte la parole est à notre collègue
monsieur Gérard
Cornu
bonjour Gérard
bonjour monsieur le le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues à titre personnel monsieur le
ministre je l'ai déjà dit je ne suis pas
favorable au travail
dominicain non pas uniquement pour des
raisons religieuses mais pour des
raisons sociales familiales et je crois
qu'il est important de veiller à ce que
la vie
associative les association culturelle
la vie sportive de nombreux clubs
sportifs qui jouent le dimanche de
veiller à ce que le travail dominical ne
se généralise pas
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça je suis
un homme pragmatique et je dois
reconnaître que la proposition de loi
après discussion à l'Assemblée nationale
me paraît juste et équilibré et
d'ailleurs je voudrais remercier les
rapporteurs aussi bien à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'au Sénat pour avoir
travaillé bien en amont et réalisé en
fait par un jeu
d'amendement une bonne proposition de
loi juste et équilibré alors l'objectif
poursuivi n'est en effet nullement comme
on l'a trop souvent prétendu d'ouvrir
les vannes au travail dominical dans
tous les commerces et tous les services
en tout point du territoire ce n'est pas
vrai bien au contraire la proposition de
loi qui nous est soumise permet de
stabiliser le cadre existant elle permet
d'éviter la rupture brutale d'équilibre
de
consommation et d'équilibre du réseau
commerçant et je pense et je pense en
particulier bien sûr au commerce de
proximité qu'il faut absolument
préserver elle permet aussi de garantir
les équilibres sociaux et familiaux
ancrés dans notre quotidien et que nul
ne songerait à remettre en cause surtout
en cette période de crise si ça avait
été si ça n'avait pas été le cas je
n'aurais pas voté cette
proposition le texte qui nous est
vise surtout à simplifier des situations
trop complexes en effet on le sait bien
le régime d'autorisation actuelle qui
repose sur un critère lié à la nature
des biens vendus est à l'origine d'un
abondant contentieux l'introduction d'un
régime simplifié d'autorisation de plein
droit permettra de réduire
considérablement les situations floues
nombreuses source d'un contentieux
toujours néfaste à l'activité
commerciale et sur le point central de
la définition du critère de la zone ou
commune d'intérêt touristique visé par
le texte il ne s'agit pas comme on a pu
l'entendre ici et là d'ouvrir la boîte
de Pandore puisque le classement
ouvreend droit au régime dérogatoire en
matière d'ouverture dominicale des
commerce longtemps débattu à l'Assemblée
sera exclusivement réalisé sur le
fondement du code du travail qui repose
sur des critères
précis bien connus si bien que
l'ouverture en question devrait
concerner finalement et là je pense
qu'il faut quand même reprendre les
chiffres devrait concerner finalement
environ 500 communes et 200000 salariés
supplémentaires qui s'ajouteront mes
chers collègues aux 7 millions et demi
de Français qui travaillent déjà le
dimanche soit régulièrement soit
occasionnellement ce texte tient donc au
total davantage de la
simplification toujours bienvenue que de
la Révolution sociétale en posant enfin
comme principe le volontariat des
salariés en consacrant le droit au refus
ce texte est une expression du principe
de la liberté du travail auquel derrière
le président de la République la
majorité souscrit et auquel au fond on
ne que peut que souscrire surtout en
période de crise l'introduction par les
députés du principe du volontariat
réversible a opportunément parachev le
dispositif j'en
terminerai monsieur le ministre avec une
question et une
suggestion une question d'abord les
grandes surfac alimentaires ne sont pas
incluses dans le dispositif on l'a
rappelé jusque là autorisé à ouvrir
jusqu'à 12h le dimanche et ce sur
l'ensemble du territoire elles pourront
désormais ouvrir jusqu'à 13h partout en
France je crois que ça ne peut pas nuire
C ce supplément d'unur ne peut pas nuire
au commerce de proximité mais je
voudrais monsieur le ministre vous poser
cette question qu'en est-il du régime
des grandes surfaces alimentaires qui
réalise un chiffre d'affaires conséquent
en non
alimentaire la distinction entre
alimentaire et non alimentaire
continuera-t-elle d'être effectué sur la
base des critères posés par la cour
d'appel de Paris dans l'arrêt contre
du 2 février 1989 à savoir le chiffre
d'affaires réalisé dans les différents
rayons les surface occupé en mè Carr et
l'effectif employé dans ses rayons ça
c'est à mon avis très important que vous
vous exprimiez là-dessus par ailleurs la
grande surface alimentaire située dans
le périmètre du puce ou en zone
touristique visée par le texte
aura-t-elle la possibilité d'ouvrir ces
rayons blancs c'est l'électroménager et
rayon brun lai les télé les ordinateurs
uniquement donc les rayons blancs et
brun uniquement et dans ce cas toute la
journée du dimanche donc ça c'est quand
même très important en clair a-t-on
raison ou non de craindre le
contournement de la loi par la grande
distribution j'aurais ensuite une
suggestion à formuler concernant les
dérogation accordé par les maires 5
dimanches par an je crois qu'il faut
simplifier alléger le travail
administratif vous l'avez plusieurs fois
évoqué et je vous demande d'être
attentif sur cette suggestion la
procédure est lourde notamment pour les
petites communes et il convient de
réaffirmer et vous vous le voulez
l'autorité du maire dans la délivrance
de ces cinq autorisations il me semble
que la concertation préalable a priori à
la prise de l'arrêté est inutile car les
réponses sont connues à l'avance et le
maire d'ailleurs n'en tient pas compte
bah tout tout simplement on demande au
syndicat on connaît la réponse à
l'avance on et donc finalement le maire
ne tient pas compte puisque il donnera
son autorisation directement il
suffirait je pense que celui-ci prenne
son arrêté et qu'après contrôle par les
services de l'État il avertisse les
syndicats et les organisations
patronales bah oui ça sera beaucoup plus
simple et comme on a tous la volonté de
simplifier je pense que ça serait
beaucoup plus simple mais la réponse
elle est toujours la même
alors donc elle n'a plus aucun intérêt
la réponse des syndicats puisquelle est
toujours la
même mais elle est la même aussi elle
n'a aucun intérêt non plus mais oui
c'est ben c'est pour ça que c'est le
maire qui doit être
souverain donc cette proposition de loi
réaffirme le principe du repos dominical
et adapte les dérogations à ce principe
dans des conditions de pragmatisme et
d'équilibre qui emporte l'adhésion
d'autant que finalement ce sont les
étudiants qui devrai en être les
principaux bénéficiaires je vous
remercie de votre
attention vous venez de suivre une
partie de la discussion générale de la
proposition de loi sur le travail du
dimanche merci